the aclu
has submitted a petition to the supreme
court and actually has reached the
supreme court where they are
well they're stating unequivocally that
women should be forced to
sign up for the draft and i know a lot
of people in the comments are like wow
the aclu actually fighting for equality
like
women should have to do the draft too
and i'm kind of like nobody should have
to do the draft i'm not for the draft
so i don't know i feel about that i
understand it's equality but i'm kind of
like how about you just stop requiring
dudes to sign up for the draft
there is an interesting conversation in
that though because conscription
in some ca in some aspects it will i
mean it makes sense if
a foreign adversary of the us literally
dropped you know
troops onto our beaches and started
storming the streets and whatever
yeah we'd have to defend ourselves
there's a really interesting
conversation around that
and then we got some other stories too
this is crazy a dc
news anchor made a comment about fat
people
not they shouldn't be allowed to get the
vaccine before anyone else
and he got fired because of it so we'll
talk about that we'll talk about some of
the other
other issues of the day we've got we've
got things around that
and we've actually got a very famous
movie star hanging out with us
ethan sipley you want to introduce
yourself hello i'm ethan deplete thanks
for having me tim uh just
real quick what do you do who are you
i'm an actor i have a podcast called
american glutton
um i i have a movie coming out
later this year and i've been in some
movies that maybe some people have seen
and television shows right yeah yeah i
think i think people are probably
familiar with you definitely
and i'm wearing i'm wearing your hoodie
yeah it's cool hoodie i liked it
so ethan gave me this american glutton
hoodie and i thought it was an anarchy
hoodie
that's pretty cool but i'm like i don't
wear it anyway you know
so there you go so uh yeah yeah
definitely we'll talk about some stuff
i'm really interested to talk about
hollywood actually because the way covet
has changed everything
yeah before the show we're we're having
a kind of interesting conversation about
what this is going to mean for like
big a-list actors when movie theaters
don't really exist in the same way so
we'll talk about that stuff sure
was it got luke hanging out i really
like the colors of that hoodie
and those women better get ready because
the united states just bombed
syria and uh everyone's talking about a
toy potato so
everything's going great welcome back
beautiful amazing human beings my name
is zuckerdawski of we are change.org if
you wish to support me you can very
easily by purchasing my shirts like the
one i'm wearing right now that says the
media is a virus which you could get
exclusively on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com thanks for
having me that's a spicy shirt
it is but the media is the virus oh
yeah we got ian hey everybody what's up
ian crossland you know me i got a uh
nasa jacket i was a little cold up here
so we uh we're throwing uh
the awesome hoodie in this thing yeah
yeah i don't work for nasa or anything
ethan's good to see you
ethan was in one of my favorite movies
of all time mall rats i just found out
yep yelling blowing
do you remember who i was yet yeah okay
keep thinking about it i love it
okay good it's one of the best scenes i
haven't seen it like the little boy is
like it's a
schooner and what do you say like you
dumb
i'm not gonna say it i call him a bad
word
yeah yeah yeah yeah nice it's a sailboat
i also attack easter
yeah that's right yeah yeah the bunny
yeah yeah yeah yeah brutal vicious
i punch it in the face or something do i
punch
it out or just
it's kind of crazy that michael rooker
is in that movie and then he went into
the marvel movies for guardians of the
galaxy and it's like man that guy's been
working forever you know what i mean
yeah we shot that movie 26 years ago
wow what was it like gorilla shooting
like on the on the scene under or did
you get around
that yeah that they had money for so we
rented them all in uh mini minnesota
and we had basically the whole mall and
we would shoot at night
um yeah but we had the run of it
also i think in america i had a scene
with stan lee
which was pretty awesome oh that's right
yeah man wow
so cool they got to get you in the
marvel movies next yeah yeah
or the tv shows whatever they're doing
that'd be cool uh we also got star patch
lists yes i am
pushing all the buttons in the corner
for ethan supply it's so super cool so
please excuse me
please pronounce it my friends we have a
really awesome sponsor today
seriously this is pocketnet.app
you can see the link in the description
below click it check it out
sign up over the past week or month
i have been becoming more and more
fervent in my rants about the need for
decentralized media to fight back
against
censorship manipulation these pressure
tactics
pocket net dot app is that they say on
their website no corporation
open source nobody can take your
subscribers away
all advertising revenue goes directly to
you as the content creator
owned and self-policed by users like you
join the revolution today
again one of the things that i've been
stressing is that when we're dealing
with
the people getting banned the
infrastructure problems how do we
maintain an open and free internet
when even the best attempts at creating
some kind of alternative network is
still centralized in some capacity
ian you've been talking a lot about
blockchain technology oh yeah and
ways to make it so it's like an
immutable system that no one can take
down yep
oh pocketnet.app i know these guys are
on the forefront
it's awesome yeah yeah super cool and so
seriously
uh grateful that they would sponsor the
show considering how much i
am absolutely stressing the importance
of something less
like this so guys if you go to right now
there's not much there but pocket net
dot app slash
tim cast news is going to start syncing
all of my videos
which will make it so that uh the stuff
can never be removed my understanding is
it can't be removed and that's what they
say so uh or they say no one can take
your subscribers away at the very least
i think this is the one of the most
important steps in making sure that
we are allowed to keep speaking as
legitimate human beings the write to
express ourselves
look whatever happens with facebook
twitter youtube any of this stuff
if we don't invent new technology and
and look at new new sites like pocketnet
then
i mean we're doomed so this is the stuff
we have to do and i i'm even
uh moving towards some kind of open
source plug-ins
that you could use for websites to help
embolden and strengthen this stuff so
definitely check it out pocketnet.app
seriously very very big thank you and
don't forget
sign up for timcast.com become a member
to get access to exclusive
episodes and segments from the tim cast
irl podcast and it helps
also keep us alive in the event that we
get purged but let's just jump to the
first big
news story and then we'll just roll with
it it's very simple
from the hill supreme court asked to
declare the all-male
military draft unconstitutional the aclu
issued a new petition saying women
should be required
to register register for enlistment as
well
they say a new petition issued by the
aclu has made it to the supreme court
and aims to declare the historic
mail-only military draft
unconstitutional noting that the u.s
department of defense lifted the ban on
women serving in combat in 2013.
the petition specifies that the
obligation for men to register upon
turning 18 years old
has yet to be applied to women quote
thousands of women have since
served with distinction in combat
positions across all branches of the
military
the formal petition reads the
registration requirement
has no legitimate purpose and cannot
withstand the
exact scrutiny of sex-based laws
that sex-based laws require rooted in
this argument is the 1981 case
rotsker v goldberg which argued that
because american men are required to
register under the u.s law and women are
not
the mail-only draft is discriminatory
and unconstitutional
the act gives u.s presidents the power
to require mandatory conscription of
eligible adult males into the us army
but excludes women ultimately the court
held that the act does not violate equal
protection clauses under the fifth
amendment
and that the government is allowed to
develop an army in times of national
emergency
now the petition asked the supreme court
to overrule rotzker v goldberg
since women are formally allowed to
register for military service and in
combat roles
and just as an aside i don't want to
derail from this story
we have the equality act being passed by
the house which would add
sex to the 1964 civil rights act so as
far as i'm concerned ladies
start lining up and registering for the
selective service because y'all are
going to be drafted
i have a question i i didn't realize
that there was still a draft
i i realized that when i was the age for
the draft i was
obese and wouldn't have qualified i also
have flat feet but
did you guys all register for the draft
yes you did
yeah i i don't remember well
you're you're 141 do you mean you have
to if you go to college sir
like you have to apply for this register
to vote yeah yeah like when you were
doing
when you would go to the dmv they'd give
you forms it would be like i sold i
signed up for the selective service and
then
i had no idea yeah yeah now
they they say that the all uh volunteer
force is more effective
and i think that's true like the data
shows
you get a bunch of people who don't want
to be there who are scared and forced
into it you get a really
ineffective fighting force i think
that's what they learned from vietnam
so my bigger question with all of this
is i know there's a lot of guys who are
probably
laughing and cheering like yeah yeah
finally because we've seen this before
there was another attempt at
at making this happen and feminists were
outraged
they were like this is not what i wanted
when when i said i wanted equality
i do not want to have to go to war and
fight in combat or anything like that
and it's like well that's what equality
means
but i guess there's a libertarian
question in all this should there be a
draft
i mean i'm sure look like i said there's
people like guys who are like ah now you
have to
sign up for the draft i'm kind of like
nah i don't know if anybody should have
to do that right
well if you look at what wars were
fighting they're not really wars
promoting freedom they're not really
wars fighting any kind of threat and i
think henry kissinger
you know he has this famous quote he
said quote military men are just
dumb stupid animals to be used as pawns
in american foreign said that
i confronted him on it face to face
one-on-one he didn't like that question
uh but but now we need an official
correction for mr kissinger he needs to
state
uh specifically that military men and
women and women
are now just dumb stupid animals to be
used as funds for foreign policy so we
need an official correction i hope the
mainstream media pressures mr henry
kissinger to to offer this question i'm
being fascist
obviously here but but i mean obviously
i'm against the draft i mean i think
it's a ridiculous idea you look at the
wars that been started
all of them are based on false pretenses
all of them are based on
benefiting the military-industrial
complex that is now getting their lunch
with the biden presidency especially
with the latest attacks that happened
tonight
but also even before that when you look
at raytheon for an example which by the
way
a board member is now our defense
secretary that
uh of raytheon that's great yeah uh yeah
well it's it's it's very what did they
call it in the media when they described
him
um he was a person of color and that was
great
uh his diversity yeah it was it was they
talked about diversity but not his
raytheon pass and now you look at what
the biden administration is doing
raytheon raytheon just got an 85 million
dollar weapons deal with ch
chile 197 million dollar weapons deal in
egypt
245 million dollar weapons deal with the
united states and another 1.2 billion
dollar weapons deal
with u.s missile defense systems that's
what raytheon just got under a biden
presidency but wait wait you said
missile defense systems uh upgrading and
working on the military but will there
be will there be women
forced through conscription to be
manning those that's the big question
right now there there was a i remember
just a few years ago there was a crisis
we're trying to enlist
uh people in the military but now with
how
robotic everything is becoming
especially with the onset of things like
drone warfare the united states military
doesn't need as many people and with
the recent economic downturn more people
are volunteering so right now the united
states does not need to use
the draft but if there was a bigger
conflict let's just say with russia
which of course the united states
is positioning itself with especially
with tonight's actions bombing
a syrian uh you know a syrian facility
that's used by the iranian-backed rebels
uh you have to wonder that this is this
is something that might
play a big role in the future i wonder
if one of the reasons we're seeing this
it's not the first time it's happened in
the past few years there have been
attempts to get women
into combat roles and to sign up for
it's not it's not the draft specifically
it's the selective service
i think it's was called and then it's
essentially the draft database that in
the event they have to reinstate the
draft
they got everybody's info but we've been
we've been talking about war with china
for quite a bit
i mean the threat from the south china
sea and uh the threat to taiwan
i'm not entirely convinced biden's gonna
go against china in that capacity but
maybe
the u.s has currently got i think some
aircraft carriers in the south china sea
could be remnants from the trump
administration but we seem to be pretty
close to war i think
was it vladimir putin who said that uh
we're in a period it's kind of like
pre-world war ii
you know then we're looking we see
things like that we see the money supply
i don't know ethan have you seen this
stuff with the money supply skyrocketing
like just like printing money like crazy
so i wonder if they're basically saying
we need to start preparing and putting
together this database in the event that
we gotta
go fight some people you know i'm really
anti-war
and really really dislike the draft i
would have been if
vietnam one of those guys that fled to
canada probably because i didn't
want to go what's wrong with mexico
stuffed in a tube
go crawl through tunnels with a pistol
looking for dudes with aks
waiting for me like no but you sure you
want i also refrigerator for repairman
or something
yeah i don't want to get inside of a
refrigerator for a repairman is that
what you just said
i said do what what i said something
like okay
wouldn't you have been a refrigerator
repair yeah it would have been something
like that in the army and i get it
um but then they would send those guys
into the jungle you'd be like i'm an
engineer yeah you're an engineer on the
front line it was terrible terrible
but but i see a value to the draft in
that if we were invaded
you've got to get people you got to get
them armed and get them in
and and you're not waiting hoping that
they'll come to the end of the country
i'm like i'm like if we get invaded
but we don't get invaded and never have
been invaded yeah geopolitically the
united states is at a
very very big advantage compared to a
lot of other countries where it's
located
so we're in a very safe safe position as
well as many gun owners that of course
also added
another big national defense and there
was a meme showing all the crazy people
that lived all over the united states
and it was a meme saying this is why the
united states never gets
invaded uh south los angeles it was
right koreans and then under that it was
vatos
and then it was uh gang members in
chicago it was florida man in florida
hicks in texas i forgot exactly all the
other
uh representation of america but the
chicago police can't even take over
chicago america will never be invaded
fifth generational warfare is the only
way to really take over the united
states and i believe that's personally
happening right now yeah it is yeah
there was a really funny tweet i saw
earlier where it was uh uh from
i think the website was the gray zone
which is like anti-war leftist
and they tweeted information war is real
and twitter added a label this
information may have been obtained
through hacking
and then it's like twitter literally
proved the point that we try and call
out these big military firms and the
manipulation and the propaganda
twitter itself is like this is
propaganda ignore this there's nothing
to see here
so yeah you know what like i brought up
you know china and potential for war
i think we might i think you'll just see
skirmishing you know skirmishes
some little hot you know back and forth
maybe like hong kong
if if china goes for taiwan it's not
going to be
well it might be i'm not entirely sure
but i think you're right
in that you know luke we've been talking
about fifth generational warfare are you
familiar with what no i don't know what
fifth generational warfare means
basically we're past the point where
violence is effective
in allowing someone to gain control of a
population
and what we're seeing from that is like
with the culture war in the u.s
victimhood is power so if you victimize
someone you lose legitimacy
so what we're seeing now manipulation
propaganda
convince populations to join you through
information
manipulation big tech companies etc it's
going to be way more effective than
you know physically punching somebody
right and also push self-destructive
tendencies and also push
things that ultimately destroy a nation
through destroying their youth
and if you look at our youth i mean i
did a video about this today
record high suicides especially in
places where there's the most
strictest lockdowns and there's even
court cases of of major people arguing
we need to
bring back the schools because kids are
going to keep killing themselves in
record numbers like they already are
which is absolutely the lockdown stuff's
getting real bad i mean how would you
rank uh americans i mean i mean
i think you're our age throughout the
years i think it's safe to say that
things haven't been going that well for
the american people
i think i'm a little older than you guys
how old are you 44
well you're a little bit older than ian
41 but you're 10 years older than me
yeah there you go
thank god i thought you were going to
say no we're the same age
you know at the end of the day i think
that all of the things that we think of
as
having power in america are all
just ideas and so
if these structures i think that the way
to
dissolve them isn't through warm
violence for real
it is just to convince people that's
exactly what this generational war is
yeah but i i think like like if you look
at how the ussr
kind of dissolved and it got really
rough immediately following the
dissolution of the ussr
and there was a lot of scary stuff
happening over there yeah
but people just went like i don't want
to do this anymore
yeah it was a loss loss of confidence
right i'm worried about that for here in
the u.s
you know like if people stop believing
in the legitimacy of government
or of institutions it's not about
whether or not they oppose them
opposition is not the op is so so
opposition is not the opposite of
confidence indifference would be
so if you've got people who are looking
to the us government and they're saying
i believe in this government in that
it's strong and capable
and you must abide by its laws and
honest that's a big thing too
and well if people view it as not honest
and they come to oppose it
the opposition is still rooted in the
idea that the government holds power and
is legitimate
but let's say there's a system that
people find they're indifferent to
so they outright ignore that's when
government actually collapses
yeah i agree well the thing is there's a
there's a lot of people losing
confidence in the system because of
all the dishonesty there's a great
article i forgot who wrote it i forgot
where i read it but it said the reason
we have
things like you know theories about you
know government
i can't can we even say that word the oh
the c-word yeah can we even say the
c-word i don't know what's the c-word
well we want a conspiracy yeah youtube
down ranks like severely anybody you
thought
yeah i was trying to think of another
word for it i threw it to you because
you're great at that
like but when you when you look at a lot
of the conspiracy theories that you know
they're they're kind of rooted in
a lot of the bigger government lies and
there wouldn't be as many of them if the
government was just honest with us and
let's be honest
they're not honest with us in so many
instances in so many different ways
whether it's war whether it's health
whether it's diet whether it's the food
chain
whether it's big industries like the
sugar industry
we have a lot of problems with mainline
institutions that profit off of our
suffering
and talking along the lines of fifth
generational warfare i think it's very
fair to say that a lot of people have
been convinced to make very bad
decisions for themselves and i think
that's an understatement when you look
at our modern day society and where it's
headed right now
well let's play let's play devil's
advocate and say
you know when talking about the draft
and uh
specifically refresh me on what your
point was because i want to make sure i
get it correct well
the larger point is people are making
really bad decisions for themselves and
they're hurting themselves for the
benefit of the very few that have no
allegiance to
the united states so just like playing
devil's advocate
if we did end up collapsing and people
did lose confidence you know ethan you
mentioned things got really bad
post-soviet union
you know the oligarchs came isn't there
isn't there a benefit to having
even if it's bad and again playing
devil's advocate here because i'm not a
big fan of big government
but what are the benefits to having a
system in place that may be oppressive
but still functions their safety and
security but by the way it
it got bad there it doesn't have to get
bad here you know
i think i think there's a weird thing
that happens in america with the medium
with government and stuff like that you
know
the um the blue and black and and white
and gold dress
and then laurel yani how people can
actively experience objective reality
differently
now i didn't when my kids first showed
me this and said what color do you see
and i said well that's clearly i don't
remember what it i think i said it's a
a black a white and gold whatever it was
and my kid said no it's these colors i
thought
you're messing with me this is clearly i
mean objectively not the colors you're
saying it is
and they insisted and then it turns out
lots of people saw it differently
there's no room in political discourse
or or
or just culture for us to go
that person is experiencing this
differently than i am right
i really try to think about like people
arguing in line at a baskin-robbins over
ice cream flavors
and at the end of the day i'm going like
what difference does it make why are we
allowing
this to ruin our lives and why are we
obsessing on it
everybody likes a different flavor right
i did a tweet where i said we really
need to
re-engage scienceology and go deep into
it rip it apart and come back and i was
talking about the science of science
like
and so many people thought i said
scientology they were responding as if
i'd said scientology and they were angry
and it's just like misperception and
that's that's not even the blue gold
thing where you're actually literally
seeing
they actually saw something different i
do i do want to bring up though when you
mention the blue and gold thing
one of the biggest drivers of that was
people had different phones with
different color
schemes and with the laurel and yanny
thing people had different speakers so
what was really happening
i could sit with my friends oh no for
sure and listen to it and somebody's
going no i hear yanny
there's a really amazing thing someone
did where they took both
the blue and gold and the white of the
white and gold and the blue and the
black
and they cut a piece out and they moved
it left and right to show you it was the
same
wow or or yeah like like uh but it was
based on
shadowing like shading made it was like
that really looks like that's crazy how
that works
and then there's another thing that's
really funny there's a meme where it was
i think seven different phrases but it
was one sound bite
and so whichever one phrase you read you
would hear
that's that's really freaky wow i can't
remember what it was i think it was
uh like iphone 4s and then it was like
a whole bunch of different phrases and
you hear it differently
if you if you look at the word and you
read it and listen you'll hear that
right there was another crazy experiment
i saw where they had people say
and then they would play like someone
saying
ba but show the f sound and people would
hear the f sound
because they're seeing like people don't
realize how much their world view is is
is like not perfect right
yeah yeah i mean i think you make a good
point that a lot of what's going on
politically is that like
actually have you ever seen this meme
where there's a six on the ground or
it's a nine
but there's two people on both sides
looking at it saying six or nine yeah
that's like a good example of what we're
experiencing right now and it's causing
people to like want to punch each other
in the face yeah i also get
a little hung up with the idea of should
um
when we think about all of this stuff
and i hear people saying this is how it
should be
i kind of go like well that's how you
want it to be
but really what it should mean you know
even when we're talking about science
science doesn't have values people add
values to science
so right anytime somebody is saying
something should be a way i'm i'm kind
of like okay
maybe you and a bunch of people don't
want it to be that way or you and a
bunch of people do want it to be that
way and i think it's really interesting
to listen to people who say
here's this problem that i perceive and
here's a solution
that i'd like to try and enact but like
that's a rational conversation
but you know that meme where it's like
the guy goes i'm angry
and he says here's the solution i don't
know he's like i'm mad he's a solution i
don't want a solution i want to be mad
and he's burning it yeah
that's fair too you sound like a very uh
uh what what
what are the uh the leftists insult they
say radical centrist yeah
that you're like hey maybe maybe
everybody has like a different
understanding of things
no you're either in our tribe or you're
bad right well yeah i mean look at the
end of the day
i i also don't think there is i don't
think everybody should be
forced to uh adhere to the same
structures
so if if people want to be
communists i'm all for it i just don't
think
i should have to be forced to put on to
be a communist that's why i like the
sweater i thought it was the anarchist
symbol
but it's your podcast right it's just a
podcast that's why i like that i'm like
yeah yeah
we talked about diet by the way diets
are safe to talk about because there's
no military backing
unless you mess with the vegans the
vegans they're like a militia
but you know what look i'm happy to talk
to vegans and
carnivores and i don't do either of
those things but at the end of the day
there is no nobody's gonna force you to
do it so it's kind of safe you know what
i mean but but you could get cancelled
like was it uh um um adele
she didn't get cancelled but they got
really mad because she had lost all this
weight
and and again you know just for
everybody watching it's like i think i
think a core component of your podcast
has to do with your you know health and
wellness and weight loss transformation
stuff for sure
uh yes i i i think adele was a hell of a
lot more famous than me
so that's a tick against her for like
she's already
on more fragile footing um also i'm a
dude
and and we have to deal with that stress
in much different ways than gals do
and she was kind of uh you know and i
think i think it's really awesome
i i really like lizzo a lot and what
lizzo talks about
but i think adele meant something to a
lot of people so when she
stepped out of it it was crushing to
them
but i think adele should be able to do
whatever the hell heck adele wants
well i mentioned this to you uh before
the show that i knew people when i was
younger that were big fans of you
you know you're you're in these movies
and you were very you know overweight is
it or obese
i was whatever you can't defend me with
those words
well uh you know just for the truth you
know keep it keep it fresh i was
550 pounds so yeah i was morbidly
obese perhaps even more abundantly more
abundantly obese
i love it uh that phrase um not it
really
just like the pointing it out anyway but
i i knew people when i was younger that
were fans of yours because you
represented them
yeah they looked to the movies and they
finally saw hey this person's like me
and i think i think that's really
interesting especially what you
mentioned with adele because
it was probably the same thing yeah a
lot of young overweight women who see
that she's famous and successful and
talented
and then she sought to lose weight
probably because she wanted to be
healthier and take care of herself and
live longer and all of these things
make people feel bad i guess yeah i've
i've definitely had some people say i
preferred you fat um and
i just don't care like because i want to
be
the way i'm i had been wanting to be
the size i am now for so long that like
how you want me to be doesn't really
matter
and then i will say uh the flip side is
there are a ton of people out there who
also have goals that maybe they haven't
achieved
that they look at me and go like i
wasn't even necessarily that heavy
and he did this maybe it's possible for
me to and that and that
feels good what was it the experience
like growing up like how did it how did
you find yourself to become
obese and then what changed and how did
you get to where you are now
well interestingly enough when we um
think about this in political terms and
the idea of forcing people to do
things they don't want to do i was
placed on diets
starting at five years old wow and
i i never wanted to be on a diet
at five i'd never wanted to be like the
moment
i woke up and went i want to be on a
diet i want to lose weight
was the first time in my life that diets
started working and i was
22 at that point but i was also 550
pounds
also it had nothing to do with health
like it that was not a metric i was
using
i uh you know sitting in this chair
when i was uh even today i come in and
i'm testing the chair like is this chair
going to collapse
under me uh waking up every day with
swollen sore
feet you know having real knee issues
um sweating as i'm toweling off from a
shower that i had cool so i wouldn't
overheat like
these are the issues that i was like i'm
done doing that
uh health never entered into it and i
was very unhealthy
once i got my footing and i started to
become more healthy i went oh this is
this is really cool too now i'm gonna
apply this metric
as a goal and that's been something i
put but
i don't think any of it works if you're
if you're trying to force somebody to do
it so
there's a real weird conversation
happening right now in the world where
there is one team
going um obesity or
overweightness or whatever word is
appropriate is
not a metric in health and then there's
another team going
uh as a reaction to that almost you're
just lazy
um you need to lose weight and so
there's these two
bizarre battles um and i
i personally don't think either is right
i think we live in a day where
there isn't a lot of physical um
activity required certainly we're not
out hunting and gathering
food uh even even the job that the
the workplace has has gone down in as
far as like physical abilities
look at us sitting in chairs this is
your job this is amazing
you know and so at the same time
food has become cheaper and cheaper and
cheaper and like
of course people are gonna get become
overweight this is like a perfect uh
confluence of events to lead to that you
know we're the wealthiest country of all
time
ever we have a lot of overweight people
because they're all kings and now they
close the gyms
tell people to stay inside and some
countries even make sure that they can't
walk
two blocks away from where they live
right so a lot of insanity is happening
uh especially i i think
the the conversation about health has
been hijacked by so many different
individuals by so many different special
interests
and there's so many different opinions
on there i think a lot of people have a
hard time finding out what's
right for them but then also a lot of
people forget you're an individual
individually what's right for you
might not be right for someone else so
that's another big discussion
i think it's really interesting you
mentioned kind of like the libertarian
nature of it like you've got to decide
for yourself people can't force you to
do it you've got to figure out what
works for yourself as well
yeah i don't think forcing people to do
anything is is is right it doesn't work
i mean yeah i don't think so either you
said moderate when i asked you earlier
said moderation was how you did what is
that exactly
you know at the end of the day all
almost all
you know even if you're even if you're
not hyper focused on it
the principle behind um diets is
thermogenesis it's the
the way you use energy and so food is an
energy source for your body i've done
you know i'm just going to eat 500
calories a day
for two months and white knuckle my way
through it that's extreme right
taking an entire food group and
demonizing it and cutting it out of my
life that's also extreme
at the end of a few years ago i found
like if i just
spend some time counting calories and
figure out because i actually had
no idea what my body required i would
cut out carbs
and then after a while i wouldn't lose
weight anymore because i was eating too
much
steaks and avocado and butter right and
then i would just have to start reducing
that
without thinking about it but i'm going
like if i want to lose weight i have to
eat less
and then i start losing weight again
which is kind of against the principle
of the keto diet
where you're supposed to just be full
from eating a bunch of fat
yeah but at the end of the day the way
your body consumes
excess fat is by feeding it too little
now if you go really extreme
the the vasts
the vast evidence is that you're going
to relapse very few people go very
extreme
do it very quickly and then have that as
a sustainable
achievement you need to set a habit you
need to turn you need to create a
routine and then turn the routine into a
habit
and and the people who do like crash
diets and stuff they don't they're
forcing themselves
and then once they get to their desired
goal their habits return
so it's it's really about i think what
do they say it's like 21 days
just a habit yes something like that
yeah and and
and you know the other thing is
um there's there's just uh there's just
a lot of
nuance in here i can also empathize with
the idea of like when you're ready to do
it and you wake up one day and you go oh
my god i can't
be this weight anymore it's hard to
breathe you know um
i'm sweating all the time my feet hurt
my back hurts
you want it fast you want to you know as
i wanted it fast you want to get that
weight off as quick as possible
yeah it's very hard to like take a step
back and go this is going to take a lot
of time and a lot of hard work that's a
really hard proposition to make for
people and also
rewinding a lot of the kind of
establishment conditioning that's
brought on to people that starts off as
their children in school if you look at
a lot of the school
lunches they are absolutely horrible for
you if you look at that food
triangle that the government recommends
for you it is absolutely horrible for
you if you look at a lot of the fat
that's being
uh banned and not used in large
supermarkets that's because of a sugar
industry banning it for you and then the
larger consequences of that are not even
talked
about what do you see though is you see
a lot of mcdonald's commercials you see
pepsi commercials telling you to get a
covet
test you see government officials
telling you where masks social distance
but
that's it predominance where's the go
outside
yeah like go for a walk get some
exercise where's the sleep where's the
meds you know
you know why i always wondered why it is
they put psychoactive stimulants in our
sodas
and i'm like it really is a sweet deal
for these fast food companies
you get a double a big mac with extra
sauce and an extra-large super-sized fry
or whatever
and then you eat it and it makes you
feel miserable so then you guzzle down
a half gallon of psycho of soda chock
full of psychoactive stimulants
you better be careful be careful tim the
the thought police are going to go after
you for attacking woca cola now
be careful but but no i always i
remember when i was younger i'd be like
watching someone eat this is really
awful food
and they'll go oh i feel so i can't move
and then they would take the
the you know the two quart cup of
coke or pepsi and then chug it and be
like now i feel good i'm like yeah
caffeine is a stimulant you're like you
know what you know what really blows my
mind
you guys ever see those commercials
where it's like a really big fat guy
and he's like eating a giant pizza with
his friends and then he goes
and it's like do you have heartburn take
this drug and i'm like dude stop eating
the pizza it's like
it's it's hurting you yeah non-stop
commercials and all these other
supplements take that i remember being
in kentucky once
and seeing at a diner this morbidly a
beast
family and instead of like regular like
drinks you know like regular drinks just
standing on their table they had those
huge soda bottles and they had an infant
baby
and the infant baby was obese too and
they were literally giving the baby
the coca-cola like this baby i'm like
why i just i i lost a little bit of hope
and humanity yeah my hope is still there
i'm very
optimistic but seeing that seeing these
really large people
feeding their child child just all the
woke
hold on hold on this is there's serious
problems here i mean what's what do you
do
you know michael bloomberg wanted to ban
didn't he try to ban large sodas or did
he actually do it
in new york he banned he tried i don't
think he was successful you know
i have i can't say that i think any food
thing is bad i think it can be used in a
way that
goes against how you want it to act in
your body
but at the end of the day i think that's
up to us you know what i mean like we
didn't
all out ban cigarettes other than san
francisco
but like they tax the heck out of them
and they bar
you can't go into buildings anymore with
cigarettes so they found a way
you know make it so you can't smoke yeah
i mean i guess it's because it's
unhealthy to other people
um but at the end of the day we still
allow people to smoke
you know just gotta go in the park and
not stand near anybody right and then
you can have your cigarette well
everyone's vaping now too and then they
banned that
right i i don't think look there's a ron
paul video we referenced the other day
and it's just one of the greatest videos
ever did you see this
from 1988 oh it's just so good he's
talking about
the government shouldn't regulate drugs
because the government can't make you a
good person
you have to choose and then at the end
he's talking to some guy and he goes
he's like the government's not going to
make you a good person why does how
about the government puts you on a diet
you're a little overweight
and then everyone in the audience is
like boo boo and i'm like but he's
making a good point well but they also
shouldn't
maybe shouldn't subsidize drugs like
that sugar industry the aspartame
industry and the hypothesis
subsidized yeah if the government's
gonna get involved there's going to be
an underground mafia market of people
selling
large sugary drinks everywhere
prohibition doesn't work
it never did work no matter what it is
every time government gets involved it
screws people over let's just be honest
with ourselves
what we do need is personal
responsibility and not the government
intervening telling you
about food triangles that are absolutely
wrong not subsidizing and running with
big sugar industries and other
industries
not running with gmos and monsantos that
has a revolving door within the fda
maybe maybe without government we
wouldn't have so many people that
are so dependent on these chemicals it's
true but you got to protect the kids
like we used to sell
cigarettes to kids there used to be like
joe camel the cartoon character and the
government had to ban those because the
market wanted to get him hooked
more importantly there was medical
doctors telling you to smoke because it
was good for your health keep that baby
okay so keep that in mind especially
when you have medical doctors
now because medical doctors could be
bought and sold just like politicians
could be bought and sold and people need
to remember
that let's let's get into the into the
government stuff as it pertains to this
because we have this story
from this is from the advocate and they
say
gay dc newscaster suspended over fat
shaming vaccine tweet
blake mccoy tweeted that he was annoyed
obese people were getting access to
vaccines
now i wonder if they have the actual
tweet he said
let's let's see uh okay let me read the
story we'll try and get to the
he says i'm annoyed obese people of all
ages get priority access
before all essential workers mccoy who
works for wttg a local fox affiliate
tweeted tuesday
when most stayed home we went to work
every day last march april may and every
day since putting ourselves and loved
ones at risk
vaccinate all essential workers then
obese
this is a really interesting point
because when we talk about universal
health care
i actually deeply and emotionally i
understand that's not logically
love the idea of universal health care
like just just just think you know look
i know so many progressives that are
like we have to do this why don't we
and i'm like i feel you man i feel i
feel this
it wouldn't it be great if we lived in
this wonderful world where everybody was
just cured of all illness and we had
these
robots come like an elysium and they
have these things you lay in and it
cures your cancer
i want it i love it but we have we have
very serious issues to contend with
the allocation of resources and in this
capacity was this guy
wrong first of all i mean it's an
opinion he's annoyed okay fine
but real quick it's he's talking about
there are people who live certain
lifestyles
that many would consider to be
irresponsible and now they're going to
get priority access to vaccinations
before
essential workers the people who are
stalking our shelves and putting
themselves at risk i mean he's got a
good point doesn't he
i think that the the argument that that
he's relying on though is this
this faction i don't know what they're
called
i think it's the there is a version
every size yeah and and they really are
advocating that obesity they don't even
like that word but obesity is not
a metric of health so i think in that
sense
he probably felt very safe saying that
right because if it's not a metric of
health why
prioritize now we also know that the
science
says that it's a major component in
covid deaths it's a huge one of the
bigger comorbidities is being obese
right
and age and those are kind of like the
magical triangle of
you're in real trouble if you if you get
covered with these things
but to in his defense i believe
he might be relying on this argument
that
you know cosmo just had a cover that
with a with a hefty gal
that said this is healthy um
this is becoming more of a mainstream
idea
yeah yeah it's literally a woman
who is uh we have it right here
cosmopolitan this is healthy
11 women on why wellness doesn't have to
be one size fits all
she's i'm i'm fairly certain she's
morbidly obese well here's the thing i
look at that and i
i have so many reactions number one i
was
overweight so i know anytime something
like that happens
you're gonna have a ton of people going
she's fat she's lazy and this makes me
feel like uh
that's not fun right as a as a person
who spent
most of their life overweight that's not
a fun conversation that's gonna be
brought up
over and over and over again which this
was when it came out um
the other thing is that gal might be
healthy
as a person however i understand this is
marketing if you had a picture of a
cowboy with a cigarette and it said this
is healthy
we would all go they're saying the
cigarette is healthy so that is clearly
saying being overweight is not a metric
of health
scientifically that's not sound now
right however we want to
value that i don't care if you
if you give a [ __ ] about this thing or
you don't
it doesn't matter to me i i don't think
that health is the be-all
end-all of like everybody should be
healthy not necessary in my view well
that's one of the biggest hurdles to
universal
healthcare you know and and you know ian
brings up quite a bit because
i i i should consider this more often
but
if we're going to say we're going to be
allocating you know a trillion dollars
you know in a certain amount of time
period to fund health care
and then you have a lot of people who
are morbidly obese eating too much
not exercising and riding around on
rascals
that's going to strain the health care
system it is it is a metric of health it
does contribute
and so everyone else has to then pay for
that so you you'll hear a lot of people
say listen
i'd love to pay more taxes to provide
for better healthcare for everybody
but does that mean i'm gonna be paying
for people and incentivizing bad
behavior
well in in that scenario would people
who smoked
be relegated to a lesser tier of health
care
i think that's where things get scary
because people say you know you create
second-class citizens
now i think more worryingly would be if
you adopted bernie sanders plan which is
to abolish private health insurance
i'm not for that i think we need like a
base level care
a lot of people say we have it but no
there's there's medical bankruptcy we
need a base level care
sup and then we need supplemental
private insurance but
i think a lot of people would argue you
can't have universal health care and
then tell people they're not allowed to
have access to it
but i do think it's a good argument you
smoke cigarettes okay well then you're
gonna get
you know you're gonna be pay a premium
or something maybe the challenge is
how many things will we add to the list
of detriments
in your plan so let's say we tell
everybody you're gonna get you're gonna
you're gonna pay a three percent tax
you know per per year or whatever to
cover universal health care it'll
probably be way more than that to be
honest
but let's say it's three percent now if
you smoke cigarettes it's five percent
if you're obese it's
it's five percent if you smoke
cigarettes and you're obese at seven
percent you've got to pay more and more
and more of your income to cover those
costs
then you know what else do we add to the
list do you drive fast cars
do you like jumping off buildings and
then you'll find there are fit people
who are like dude just because i like
riding my bike and i'm at risk and
then you're trying then you're just
talking about taking the private
insurance that already does this
and turning it into a government
institution and getting rid of
competition which just
that in the end doesn't make sense yeah
and destroying everything and making it
worse for everybody by making
a dmv like system i remember a few years
ago hearing a story about a teacher's
union planning to put teachers on
on fitbits and these like health watches
and they had to have a number of steps
per day and to have a number of physical
activities per day if they wanted their
medical
insurance and if they didn't they
wouldn't get medical insurance a part of
the larger teachers union
so i remember hearing stories about that
and that's more likely what's going to
happen
with the larger kind of technocratic
overlords that are becoming our rulers
of our daily lives
and you're going to have to probably
tell the gospel of dr fauci
you're going to have to do five hail
marys to how beautiful and amazing
a government is then you're going to
have to do probably a mile walking
doing hard labor in some of the gulags
and then you'll get free health
insurance so
my prediction for the future uh is is
that personally well this is uh
i googled it cs monitor says this was
back in 2018 a proposed uh oh
it's just it's telling me let me see if
i can refresh it there we go a proposed
change to west virginia's public worker
health plan
would have asked teachers to download a
mobile fitness app called go365 and earn
points on it
using a fitbit or other fitness tracker
designed to monitor the user steps taken
heart rate other metrics
those who declined or who compli
complied but failed
turn enough points would face a penalty
of 500
each year does that make sense
uh yeah because they did this at my
workplace so i worked at a hospital and
they were able to offer us health
insurance at a discounted rate
you would go in and they would take your
measurements and if you were within the
parameters for cholesterol
for weight for blood pressure for all
these different things
they would give you a discount so it
made it it was like subsidized through
them and that
then it was even less expensive if you
were healthy enough
if you were over they would help you
find a way to solve your problem they
would help you lose weight they would
help you get your cholesterol under
control
and if you weren't able to do that you
would just pay more for health insurance
and now combine that with the elon musk
brain chip
and we're going to be cyborgs they're
going to be ruled by the that's
you know that's how the borg started in
star trek right everybody knows the
board you know the borg right
the they're the robot people who are
like resistance is futile you will be
assimilated
in star trek data wasn't to board no no
no he was an android
and so the borg character in star trek
is basically
it's this big cube they have cube ships
that fly around and
they enter they'll they'll see like
other you know humanoid aliens and then
say your technology and culture will be
assimilated into
the borg collective and they're all a
hive mind of like
non-individual the story the backstory
is i understand it i could be not a good
enough trekkie on this one is that
they were a regular human-like species
and they kept implementing medical
technology to improve their well-being
and and linking themselves in networking
until eventually it formed a hive mind
and they became
this zombie-like collective that
consumes people
so you might think it's silly when luke
brings up the elon musk brain chip stuff
but they very well could do in the
future say listen
if you want access to the healthcare we
need to be able to track your health you
need to get the
the neural link you need to get the
implant you could argue that
us being so wired in twitter is like the
zombie hive mind
already like oh death tier one you know
and we're resistors
like we're resisting the you know the
the whatever whatever faction isn't
necessarily right wing or whatever those
who resist the mainstream
are those like pushing back against the
hive mind
culture those who just follow along do
what the media says don't question
versus those who do
sure yeah well already we live in a
society where insurance companies data
mine social media posts in order to deny
people coverage on
whether it's health or real estate or
even car so there's already elements of
this that are extremely creepy
especially when you look into the
metadata
that facebook has on you that twitter
has on you that google has on you that
is absolutely frightening
and when you calculate society to such a
controlled level
it is bound to become dystopian
and out of control and something that
there's hollywood movies made about but
when it's happening in real life people
are going to be like oh this is good for
you ethan
did you know that facebook knows when
you poop i don't have facebook yeah you
do advance
you do have facebook yes and it still
knows you you do have facebook whether
you signed up or not yeah
and it does know if if you're my friend
and i have your number in my phone
facebook has your contact has your
information has you databased in their
system
it's called a shadow profile that's not
fun so so here's what ends up happening
right
so your your mom has you well probably
listed in her phone as your name
but you might have her in your phone as
mom or you know mother or whatever
then you've got a significant other or a
friend your sister has you in
as maybe just you know ethan or maybe
she puts like ethan bro
or ethan brother or something like that
when they sign up for facebook
facebook says would you like to help you
know we can help you find your friends
and they go you got it
now they have your mom's information
your uh your sister's information your
brother
your your kids your grandparents your
cousins
all of these other people your best
friend who has your name
in his phone book and that's just off
the phone alone there's other ways they
collect your data
through going to websites that have the
facebook login you'll go to a website
and say log in through facebook facebook
has an app that's tracking your data
right so the interesting thing is
they'll they'll take your phone
your phone number when you log into
messenger not you specifically but
someone and they'll find
a phone number that says mom they'll
then find that someone else has that
phone number listed as
janet they'll then have that phone
number listed by someone else as
secretary assistant and now they know
you know
ethan's mom is janet she's a secretary
assistant or whatever
and then we can look at the area code so
we know where the phone is from we can
track its location
these people all interact with this
person it's happening in this place
even if you don't sign up for facebook
they collect all that data from other
people about you
and you never consented to that right so
i don't know if they know when you poop
but if you've got
facebook on your phone they know when
you poop right
that's um disturbing
[Laughter]
what are your social medias uh that you
use i use
instagram and then i always click the
button
post on twitter but i don't really use
twitter
instagram is owned by facebook right so
you have facebook facebook
they know when you poop yeah i use that
i use that example because it's the
silliest
but still a violation of people's
privacy right and you got to understand
they know the other things you're doing
you know private things at home in the
bedroom
they probably know the craziest thing is
you might not realize this but there's
little things you do
that you don't understand correlates
with certain behaviors so you might go
on your phone
and look up you know 3d 3d uh
illusion sailboat and they know that
people who do that
actually correlate with people who like
eating pepperoni pizza
and you have no idea how one day you can
advertise that says extra large
pepperoni
and you're like how did they know i
wanted that well it's because you did a
google search for a
3d illusion sailboat yeah and there's a
weird correlation there used to be this
thing on the website
on the website this would be this thing
on the internet i can't remember what it
was called but it was in the in the late
90s early 2000s
and they had a series of tests what they
did was they asked men and women
random questions and then they found a
pattern
in answers that the answers women would
give and the answers men would give so
one of them was choose choose one of the
one of the below
like one choose one of the objects below
and it would be like a roller skate
a green circle a picture of a surfboard
and a picture of like a steamboat
and for some reason men would choose one
and women would choose something else
and then what they do is after after 10
000 people do the test they find
70 of women would choose this one and 70
of men would choose this one and we have
no idea why
but with that data they could then
determine whether you were a man or a
woman
so it's really crazy how we don't
understand you know deep down these
differences
but with that they can track everything
you do
they they know more about you than you
probably know about yourself yeah
i mean this is a real good argument to
get rid of my phone
yeah i do have a hammer if you'd like to
borrow it and we can
we are close to the weekend hillary
clinton we could just give up on society
and start a new civilization
we're basically in the woods man the
mountains and the woods and all that
stuff i mean but you know honestly
with everything that's been going on
it's one of the reasons why i decided to
get away from these cities
and move out to the middle of nowhere i
tweeted about this earlier
we have this we have this story let's
just go for it here we go everybody
the pod people the new york post says
high school band
uses individual tents to keep practicing
during pandemic
it's a bunch of students standing in
these are i think are like these are not
tense there's something else
they're calling them tense but they're
like personalized garbages garbage
they're upright fabric they are fabric
they're up
you ever get one of those like laundry
hampers made of wire and it like pops
into place
imagine that but big and you're standing
in it
these people died playing the trombone
do this uncomfortably
like standing standing at a weird wedged
in there this is crazy to me that people
are
are doing this stuff and it was funny
because uh
as i mentioned this often i i learned
from the best michael malus on how to
properly tweet
you you tweet in ways where you leave it
ambiguous enough to where it can be
interpretable
but you still express your either
disdain or support and i said
if people are doing this you know this
is you're insane but
you know what at this point i don't care
what you do do whatever you want i'm
going to go over there in the middle of
the woods
and i'm going to you know get a little i
got a bo i got a bow and arrow we're
getting chickens
yes i kept saying this you know what i'm
going to go buy chickens i tweeted
and then i bought some chicken coops you
know we'll get some chickens
and i look at the stuff it was funny
when i had a bunch of people say like
you're so dumb tim do you think the
students should spit on each other and
i'm like
they should not go to school if it's
seriously that bad
don't put them in this ridiculous this
is awesome i gotta say
i hear this and i think god thank god
some kids get to go to school right
because in
we don't have school in california right
now yeah yeah but i understand that too
but it's also you don't need to do this
like you're
you're spitting into a device and you're
standing far away from someone else
this makes no sense can we pull up the
picture of the kid with the trombone
yeah we got it because he is extremely
uncomfortable
and imagine imagine hi and he's also a
bigger guy
but but imagine paying the state to
treat your children like this
this is absolutely absurd and we wonder
why kids have a mental health crisis
this is a part of the reason wired
actually had a very good article today
that i was reading and it's titled
it's ridiculous to treat school
children um like covet hot zones
and they pretty much came to the
conclusion that it's not
and that this is all pandemic theater
and i absolutely agreed with them
because there's a lot of
preliminary science and statistics and
reports
showing how there's absolutely very
little threat of covid in schools
and children transmit the virus very
differently than adults do
this this is this is from last year
though this is from last may yeah but
still it's
but it but it's it has been true that
children don't spread i mean let's
let's be real what's the survival rate
for people under the age of from from
the ages of like like 11 to 20 or
whatever is like 99.999 percent
yes and i guess the argument is but
they'll spread it to grandma and it's
it's always just like well then you know
keep grandma safe i sleep
isolate use sanitizer and why why you
know
i read this really interesting blog post
i remember it was a while ago
and it was from an older person who said
i don't understand why you're asking
the younger generation to sacrifice
their lives for the older generation
the older generation typically
sacrificed their lives for the next
generation
someone who's in their 80s like do you
guys remember what happened with uh
fukushima
the nuclear plant title tsunami hits it
radioactive waste and then the elderly
volunteered to go into the plant to
try and stop the leak and solve the
problem because they were like well
we're going to die soon anyway
we'll we we will sacrifice ourselves for
the youth i actually know somebody uh
luke and i
knew somebody who was older and and lost
her life providing tours to journalists
in the media top
get the word out and explain what was
going on in this area she ended up
getting cancer
and so with you know the utmost respect
she was an amazing individual
the older generation willing to risk
them you know their lives to help
the next generations survive this to me
is is absolutely insane yeah
making the kids sacrifice their
education their well-being their
upbringing their food their nurturing
for the older generation look i don't
want anyone to die
and i think ultimately it's the choice
of the older generation i want to keep
them safe and protected
i don't want to force anybody to
sacrifice anything i just think it's
interesting that we've decided as a
society that
it's better to sacrifice the kids
well-being
for you know a 99 point i believe for
the people above 70 it's a 99.5
survival rate no i'm sorry 97.5 survival
rate i just think there's some kind of
imbalance there
maybe we need to address the harder
questions about you know how we deal
with this maybe we need to make sure
that
the elderly are protected i think maybe
andrew cuomo needed a lesson in that
regard that he never uh
got not just him but these other
governors as well
i don't know man i just i think these
kids you know when you look at the masks
you look at the schools
there are kids who are now spending a
large portion of their lives over a year
not seeing strangers faces not seeing
expressions
not seeing mouths move when you look
when you look at a person's face
you know you can tell people can tell
when when someone's faking a smile
because a real smile your eyes actually
you know
smile as well you smile with your eyes
and when even when someone's wearing a
mask
you can see when they're smiling the way
their eyes move but what about a kid who
doesn't know
and hasn't had the chance to develop
those social understanding
they're going to be socially stunted i
mean the most important formative years
and we're damaging these kids over this
stuff
stuffing them in these tents to play
music you know what man
if it were me i wouldn't even go to
these schools when i was 14
i was in i went to high school about two
months and then i just one day was
walking to school stopped turned around
and went home and that was it
do you kind of want to hear what it
sounds like when they're playing in the
tents though
yes i do yeah a little curious yeah i
wish there was videos of that
yeah but but you bring up an important
point first of all that fukushima trip
was insane i don't know why i went with
you
but we did um second of all it's
hopefully we don't get thyroid cancer
yeah
um yeah so that gives me a little bit of
anxiety as well thanks tim
uh thanks for reminding me what it's do
i try not to think about that but but
when we talk about these school children
you know a lot of them who do get the
chance to go back they're forced
to social distance they're forced to
mask but they're also
in some schools forced to wear tracking
beacons
that go off if they get too close to
other students
and they get in trouble and they get
punished by standing or walking too
close to other people
so that's the level of absurdity imagine
going to a school
in your developmental years are
authoritarians
screaming at you not to be close to
another human being
or in some instances like in buffalo
telling you that all white people
are racist you know just like the story
that we covered yesterday that's why
again i'm a big proponent
of homeschooling homeschooling networks
uh are something that people should look
into
i know it's very difficult for people to
raise children independently but there's
networks out there
that let you do this in a way that's
very cost effective
that that's that saves you a lot of time
and also lets you be a part of a
community that teaches
your children the values that you
believe in personally
rather than of course having a
government come in there and scare the
other
crap out of your children so i think
everybody here seems to be fairly on the
uh
not big fans of government scale i
suppose not i don't want to say
anarchist luke is definitely the uh
resident government i just don't feel
good
i just don't stupidity like this they
found covid in an ice cream factory in
china there's news
that i don't know thousands of ice cream
tested positive for cover that it was
living in the fat cells and you're
saying that like the
greatest co-morbidity is obesity where
there's a lot of fat cells so
that they're obsessed with the air and
transmitting it through the air when
there's evidence that it's in the food
is but completely driving me insane you
have to breathe it in though right
no you don't have to breathe you can eat
it too you can get covered from eating
it apparently that's what was happening
with this
why they were recalling all this ice
cream weird uh well
i have not heard that yeah yeah which is
odd you would well no
the media would be like red alert nobody
ian's right because in china they do the
butt swabs yep
it's in your digestive tract you heard
about that right there's reports
i did i didn't read a proper report i
saw him probably don't want to
right you know but like the joke i made
was shut up and put on your mask
otherwise the butt swabs are next
there's some preliminary reports that
u.s diplomats were forced to get those
swabs up there you know what no
i haven't seen it they're confirmed i
haven't seen it confirmed but
i'm seeing some reports right now you
said you know what are you saying but
or who no no no they're they're butt
doxes oh okay
yeah they're you know so so there's
reports of us diplomats being forced
to do this uh haven't been confirmed yet
so we're looking up i'm i'm trying to
verify this as we're speaking right now
americans being forced to do it i
wouldn't be surprised the gateway pundit
reported on it now
how are you handling i'm checking out
the sources how are you handling family
life
through covet you got kids you said
earlier i have kids um
you know the in the beginning we didn't
know what was happening
and it was real scary and we didn't
leave my house
and they i have two kids in college on
the east coast they came home
uh and we just kind of hunkered down and
and then we figured out how to live you
know i think you know
as a person who doesn't do well with
the imposition of somebody else's rules
i also
look around and recognize that there
have always been rules
and the happiest i ever feel is when i'm
just trying to
succeed despite them if that makes sense
yeah yeah so like it's not everything's
not the way i want it to be
but it's kind of just like a new game to
navigate that's that's
i think that's one of the smartest ways
to look at it too you know that one of
the ways i've always treated is
i'm not super concerned i'm definitely
concerned when we see the rise of
authoritarianism
i know i can survive it i know that you
know i'm clever enough to find my way
through the new rules to make things
work and all that stuff
i do worry about other people i also
worry about the principles of the matter
you know people have a right people have
rights to be free to speak their minds
and so there are there are definitely
problems in that regard we have to have
us
we have to have like a baseline of when
we go too far to to not allow something
like that you know what i mean
yeah no totally i don't know i think
the way i try to think about it is
the way i want it to be it's not always
going to be the way i want it to be it's
never been exactly the way i want it to
be but that's fine
um i try to give people the benefit of
the doubt and go
like i i believe people are basically
good and that the intention is safety
you know maybe not for raytheon i don't
know
i don't know if that's their intention
that's kind of the opposite oh they're
intentional
for the most part i think you have
but i think you could look back through
history and pick any
of the things we call atrocities that
are atrocities
and go somebody had in the beginning
the intention to keep some group of
people safe well look at
what was it tnt dynamite or those are
different i think but uh
you alfred nobel right he invented it
and what happened was i could be messing
the story up
i guess the intention was to help mining
you basically instead of having people
get trapped and just
you put the bombs there and you walk
away and then kaboom and then there you
go it's been done
and then people we were using as a
weapon and so one day
some newspaper accidentally published
his obituary while he was still alive
and they called him the merchant of
death
and so he saw that was like is that my
legacy so then
nobel prize was created because he
wanted to do something better
because he didn't want to be the really
you know awful
nobel prize is quite a swan song yeah
yeah but it's like uh
you know whatever your intention is for
your creation it can go in a wrong
direction right no
totally i i think but i think about that
too like the things that i would be most
critical of
with a government i try to give them the
benefit of the doubt and go
somebody is is has a concern
and they're trying you know i don't know
that that's always true
it's hard to say that uh but even like
you know our economy crashes and burns
if we don't enforce the petro dollar
let's right right right a lot of people
don't understand this you know this is a
really good point
because people are talking big right now
about joe biden bombing syria it's big
news we did talk about a little bit
and i tell people you realize that
when the us is going to war in like
middle eastern countries it's not you
know you'll hear a lot of lefting
activists say americans just want to
blow up kids and stuff like that i'll
joke and say something like that like
you know oh who else is going to do it
america loves doing it
the reality is these special interests
want money
and resources they want to build the
cutter turkey pipeline to deliver cheap
gas into europe to to dominate the
market make money but also offset the
prices for the people who live there
it's it's for them it's like hey it's a
win-win we get rich they're not doing it
because they're mustache twirling
villains we're like yeah
let's blop a country they're they're
they're saying i want something that's
going to benefit
my team yeah and they're willing to do
horrifying things to do it
and i look at that i'm like i am not
interested in funding you
blowing up and destroying a country so
you can get cheap gas into
into europe man i'm not in favor of that
yeah i i
listen morally i'm not in favor of it
either but
when we think about stuff like health
care and and your proponent for
universal health care that's not
possible
idealistically i am but right you know
not possible
if we get rid of if if we say hey we're
pulling out of the middle east
right our economy crumbles it
implodes it's done so all of these plans
that are being
argued about in america are kind of like
you know none of it survives without
those wars
well in terms of getting the oil you
know in a lot of these countries but
we're also producing what poppy and
opium
in afghanistan so there's like it's it's
about control
and a lot of things i'm not entirely
convinced though i think one of the big
arguments we saw through the trump years
was
how about we focus on energy development
in this country
that way we're not reliant on that and
we became energy independent so we
didn't need those wars anymore
and then we got the abraham accords
these are things that i think are good
and i
i before aoc came out with it i was a
huge proponent of the green new deal
i made i made a couple different
segments where i was like i like this
you know why
before they actually put the bill out it
was like
would you like to invest government
resources and taxpayer dollars into
advancing green technologies to make the
united states more
environmentally friendly and energy
independent and i was like that sounds
like the coolest thing ever
and then they actually release the green
new deal and it's like would you like
social equity to give you know women of
color access to college and healthcare
and i'm like
look i appreciate the attempt to help
people
but please don't use my ideals
for environmentalism to push your
critical race theory
because i am not a fan of that and the
green new deal became about changing the
economy and not about developing this
technology
so it was like a slap in the face the
people who actually thought we got a
good thing going
and then the people who are supposed to
be proponents of this environmental
technology
like i seriously the second page of the
bill was was all critical race theory
social justice had nothing to do with
the environment
we're going to provide college and
health care and i'm like wait wait wait
what
i thought we were going to build a
fusion reactor reach ignition man
and then we're going to have flying cars
is there anybody trying to do that
they're doing fusion there's a lot of
people working on it jpl is working on
it
yeah but we've not minor settings we
haven't reached the ignition phase is
that what is where
i think not where the fusion happens and
then the reaction outputs more energy
that's put in so
like you know ignition like a fire well
another thing to really kind of consider
here
is that um the us dollar is going to
collapse inevitably
especially with its monty money printing
especially with its money supply
and there's some people arguing that if
we end the wars in the middle east
and this reckless spending that the debt
wouldn't be as high
and we we would postpone this inevitable
collapse because we are already indebted
to such a way where it's impossible to
pay back and
uh this is something that of course is
going to fall in on itself eventually
okay but i have a question
we're able to rack up so much debt
because the trading of oil
is predominantly done with u.s dollars
around the world yes
so that offsets our ability to incur
debt
yep if we pull out we can incur
no more debt right and all the debt that
we've incurred
collapses on us it's so it's not even
necessarily about
getting the oil it's just about saying
you must use dollars
this is a system put in by henry
kissinger when of course he went over to
saudi arabia and this is the larger deal
that they have now but we saw
trump kind of throw a wrench into a
little bit one he was brutally honest he
was like yeah we're in syria we're
stealing their oil
yes we're giving saudi arabia the
weapons because we want money they pay
us a good deal
but also he uh also had a big priority
on energy where america became the
number one
energy producer in the world uh when
donald trump was in power
so yes it's it's pretty me pretty much
run through the military-industrial
complex but when you look at the larger
kind of foreign policy mishaps
not just the chaos but the money spent
they don't serve any purpose and in the
long run in my opinion they're going to
be hurting the united states because
they could enforce
the trading of you know oil on the
dollar in many different ways but
entangling ourselves in afghanistan and
spending so much money there
recklessly and and just wasting it away
is not going to
to ensure that but but ethan hit the
nail in the head yeah
we can rack up as much debt as we want
so long as we force everyone to buy oil
with our dollars
yeah so so i have this but that's kind
of like i want to say
no war morally i go this war doesn't
make sense to me yeah
morally but i recognize at the same time
what happens here if we're not doing
that this is this is a really good point
man
i'd have no problem living in the woods
you know we wait there's this joke i
will not live in the pot i will not eat
the bugs and i'm like well hold on
i'll live in the pot and i like the bugs
you know why because my pod is going to
be up in a tree
right next to a nice little river where
i'll go fishing and periodically eat
bugs
i got no problem if i had to live in the
wilderness
and learn to survive and actually work
hard to survive i actually respect that
and i would enjoy it i i i love being
out and walking through the woods
and uh i love that feeling of
accomplishment in these things
it's cool till you cut yourself sure
we'll have to learn how to make alcohol
and all that stuff but here here's the
point
it's really easy to say you know what
fine
no war let the petro dollar fail
and then so what what's the worst going
to happen americans are going to have to
learn to survive again that's not the
worst that will happen well i'm
wondering no no no no the worst that
will happen is that china will take over
and then with the matter of time you
living in the woods thinking about your
own business will eventually be under a
global
authority of chinese rule i'm i'm
thinking that the us dollar will
collapse and that the bitcoin will
become the new currency of the united
states and there'll be a whole
uprising of a wealth class that we're
like 20 year olds you know
no five years i mean we're we're in the
meme economy all right can we talk can
we talk about this though because i have
a question
92 or 4 of all
currency on earth is digital yeah did
you guys read that the uh
the fed had a glitch yesterday was it
yesterday
and three trillion dollars didn't get
moved around correctly
yep so how how is it that we don't wind
up with some kind of blockchain currency
well they're working on fedcoin okay and
the government
yeah the federal reserve i believe is
going to make a crypto you know i had
this question
you know you bring this up it's
interesting i read this story the other
day uh
fed glitch shuts down wire transfers
direct deposits and other services it
was an operational error
and i started laughing i'm like is is
the is it collapsing like is this the
end
they forgot their phrase key yeah but
here's the thing
i asked like how does your bank know you
have money
when i go to the bank when i go online
use a credit card
when i when i spend money from my bank
there's no actual money being
transferred anywhere someone just writes
a number down in a book and then someone
writes a different number down in a
different book
there's never really any currency it's
it's the interesting thing
about all this is that cryptocurrency is
actually a cryptographic code that can't
be
stolen i mean if you can break the
cryptography you can totally unwind the
network
the blockchain but the idea is because
it's an encrypt it's an encryption
you have your your private keys there's
a public key and they can't replicate
what you have without the private
information it's remarkable technology
with banks they just take your account
and they write
he has money and that's it and the
federal reserve can go offline which we
saw yesterday which is absolutely insane
if we have
a central node where everything goes all
the money and if it goes down the entire
industry is quite
wild it's a fiat system with no market
cap and only backed by the
military-industrial complex but
again back to the other point here we
don't need to make blunders
we don't need to make mistakes that
waste money in order to pepper
to push the dollar on the world stage
there's other ways to do it
china what they're doing is kind of a
different way with their belt and road
initiative
diplomacy trade investment
where essentially there's in proxy
becoming new colonizers as they were
described
to me in africa with them buying up all
the natural resources all the national
property
and china also is building their own
cryptocurrency which they're going to be
using as a global currency so so
right but think about that you were
making the point earlier
that the petro dollar is is paramount
but what happens when the fed collapses
i mean that yesterday was nuts like it
just stopped working
what happens when china launches a
crypto or they heavily invest in bitcoin
gain access to the most powerful and
dominant crypto uh
currency petrodollar will be meaningless
yeah i also worry about
uh the us trying to figure this out
simply because when you see them roll
out big like
california alone had 50 billion dollars
worth of fraud on the
on the uh that's right alone yeah that's
yep
ppp loans whatever it was 50 billion
dollars just for california
i just i i i don't mean to be so hard on
the government um you know unfortunately
the
the thing they do best is war
they don't they don't seem to have these
big programs down
that they can roll out um like the the
healthcare
website was a disaster and that's crazy
you know there were all these glitches
with the payments and stuff
um so i i do worry that
if they try to do some kind of a
blockchain currency
that i don't think it'll be the best one
right to add to your point there's this
famous meme
and it says under anarchy warlords would
take over
and it's a photo of all the presidents
sitting together of the united states
so just to add to that point but yeah i
mean the government is largely
inefficient
bureaucratic bloated and can't get
simple things done are you
gonna mail you a check for like when
donald trump did it for how much was it
was two thousand dollars that i don't
know the first one i think was a grand
wasn't it
i forgot exactly how much but government
couldn't even effectively send everyone
a check
they sent they sent non-citizens checked
in other countries dead people were
getting checked yeah what makes you
and it was even in even different
intervals if you were a different rank
based on this classification
and this irs code you would get it in
september some people would get it in
june
and it was all over the place well i i
got to be honest with you
i really don't see the purpose in
sending everybody a check
i i personally didn't need a check
yeah why did i get a check you know if
you want to be nice
give me a little break on my taxes or
whatever but but like yeah yeah
instead of giving everybody
they didn't give everybody a check there
was a there was a an income limit
okay and i i and i i think one of the
problems right now is you know biden is
saying we're going to give 1400
not 2000 because it's supplemental to
the 600 you already got and it's going
to be means tested meaning
only people who make under a certain
amount and then you start to lose it
i disagree with that the problem is i'm
not a big fan of the printing money
i think it's going to be detrimental in
the long run it's going to cause
inflation it's going to be extremely
damaging
but so long as the american people are
borrowing from themselves
okay well i guess we have to because the
economy has been
grinded to a halt the government did it
it's the government that caused the
economic shutdown and now
instead of giving people access to
resources to just it's it
the money doesn't make the system work
it just kind of kick starts
it lubricates the economy a little bit
they're not going to give everybody
the amount of money they actually need
to get the machine moving again
so i actually think if you make more
money you should actually get more money
you know why
let's say before the lockdown you're
making 70 000 a year
you dedicate you built your lifestyle
around your earnings if you were
responsible you had a bit of a savings
and you weren't living down your means
so let's say you were paying rent you
had your medical bills and you had
insurance and you had a cell phone bill
all budgeted for your income 70 000
economy stops you go to zero you've got
you know let's say you've got
three thousand five hundred dollars in
bills every month or something like that
and then someone else was making thirty
thousand and they budgeted their life
for thirty thousand so their bills are
about a thousand a month
then the government says i'm giving both
of you a thousand bucks well the person
whose life was at seventy thousand
and that's not i think that was the
average income in the united states
eighty-six thousand the median i think
is like 68.
so we're talking about an average person
now having their life completely
destroyed losing their home losing
getting kicked out
because they can't afford that small
check it you know
it goes i'm not necessarily saying
definitively give
rich people more money i'm just saying
we need to consider the fact that
someone who makes seventy thousand
dollars a year is not a rich person
right but they have different needs than
someone who is making thirty thousand in
fact maybe the answer is
just give everyone more money even the
people who were making three
thirty thousand i don't think it makes
sense to start taking it away from
people
just because they were making you know
75k or whatever
yeah listen all this money is
balanced again by the the external
dollars that are kind of
keeping this and and we're going to
reach a point where we have
now put too much inside and it's going
to tip it and it's going to be a
disaster
i don't know if you guys have seen this
chart we really got to get some monitors
set up so you can see it yeah
but it's the uh it's the m1 money stock
going back to 1959.
so this is the amount of dollars and
other like basically it says billions of
dollars seasonally adjusted
monthly from 1959 till today and from
1960
until uh about let's say about 2000 it's
just a very slow
and steady go you know so it's decades
then at 2008
it goes up a little bit the frequency of
the production of money increases
2020 happens and you know the line looks
like it goes straight up
wow just straight up from here's what it
says
in december 2019 3978
billions of dollars and then in
january in about february to march
it starts to hockey stick and then from
april to may it goes up more
and then from mate from april to may it
jumps dramatically
now some people have pointed out that
they they change the way they calculate
this in may
and that may contribute but there's also
other charts the m4 money stock and
other charts
from the financial times showing
regardless of the way they changed it
the same thing happened they started
mass printing money with these stimulus
checks
and we went from you know in march four
thousand what is it four thousand two
uh 257 to what do we got here
july 16 803 so it what quadrupled
and now it's at eighteen thousand one
hundred and five billions of dollars in
in that one money stock
i'm not an economist i can't tell you
the nitty gritty of the m1 money stock
some people have said it doesn't
necessarily matter
because it doesn't you know it's just
money in circulation or something like
that but
i'll tell you this this chart and the
other charts i've looked at
many people are pointing out it's
unprecedented and we have no idea what's
going to happen when you dump that much
money into the system um i have a
some idea uh lol do you
remember weimar germany yeah shuffling
the
deutsche marks into the into the gutter
you ever heard of zimbabwe yeah
um venezuela what did they say in brazil
what did they say that happened in may
where that they change the way they they
did you have more
data about they said the way they change
they measure the the m1
yeah it's like it's it's so i i i don't
want to read the whole thing
it just says before may it consists of
currency at the uh outside the u.s
treasury federal reserve banks
let's see um i wonder if there's just an
easy way to look at what the change was
um i'm not entirely sure the difference
is is that much
so let's see demand demand deposits at
commercial banks
where's where's the first change okay
beginning may 2020
it doesn't look like i i have to read
through it but it seems oddly insidious
that they would change the way they do
the measurements in may of 2020. after
they printed
12 trillion so they went from 4 trillion
now to 18 trillion of liquid money in
the supply
well some people are saying oh no no it
only looks that way because they change
the way they calculate it
and i'm like the the hockey sticks
started before yes or no it was february
to march march to april
april to may and then may to june is not
the biggest spike
so they say oh but the beginning of may
yeah right may to june is where we
should see the biggest spike right
you know what else is up about 400
bitcoin
what was bitcoin in november it was 13
000. it's almost exactly crazy yeah and
that was november what was it last
january look give us the talking point
what was the meme for
for bitcoin you said remember what you
said i forgot don't make me say it
say it if you if you bought bitcoin
instead of toys
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if you
bought a bitcoin instead of
toy story three the dvd you would have
10 million dollars
say that yes that's so rude yup the dvd
came out in 2010 amazing 10 million
10 million dollars and i i don't know
what it was what bitcoin was in january
last year all of you people who bought
toy story 3 on dvd
how dumb do you feel good been movies
you should have been psychic and known
to buy an obscure
obscure computer program digital
conservation currency that no one knew
about
one of my favorite memes is from the
early uh
2010s and someone was like this bitcoin
seemed uh
this bitcoin thing seems interesting
what can i do with it and then someone
said buy drunk
drugs and hire assassins on the internet
and that was they're like why would i
buy it then
but all of the and caps the anaco
capitalists were like wow count me in
and now a whole bunch of them are rich
march 12th
of 2020 bitcoin was 4857.
it's up like 1200 percent everybody's
seeing this
they're seeing the mass printing of
money and they bought bitcoin yeah even
the banks
yup even the banks big insurance firms i
think they're prepping for a total
economic reset or transition to be well
you know you know who was the biggest
holder of bitcoin right
china well they were the biggest miners
of bitcoin
we we should we should probably do an
audit someone should i think they
already did
where all the bitcoin that was mined in
china went uh because that would be a
very interesting perspective there's
also a lot of talk about a lot of
wales having a lot of control of bitcoin
that's one of the talking points that a
lot of the alternative
cryptocurrencies are making so uh again
a lot of people are also saying i've
been saying this from the very beginning
uh bitcoin could be a nsa honeypot from
the very beginning
could be we don't know i don't have any
evidence to prove that
i said this very you know well i said
this very early on but i've maintained
this
bitcoin is completely trackable every
transaction
is tracked and they have ai that know
exactly who's spending what
so we've seen all these stories where
they're like we know the far right is
spending money here and doing these
things and here's what they bought
because they can track every account in
the blockchain
so they know what you're doing they can
on monero right monero's
cryptocurrencies
they can't yeah that's why monero jumped
in value because it was like oh i can
use
this and it's untraceable that's also
why i got pulled off bit racks
last month for americans well yeah yeah
americans how
yeah in cities there's that word again
wow they want to know when you put them
in
facebook they want to control you they
want to know every little thing about
you so but maybe that's good because
people what is this the panama papers
where they were storing all that money
over here
you must understand it broke you're
right but you must understand
do you think tracking for thee but not
foreign
you think the wealthy global ultra
elites are going to be
subject to us tracking their
expenditures i would hope so no way
could you imagine if epstein was on
bitcoin and we knew exactly was buying
it's never going to happen
yeah deutsche bank got a slap on the
wrist for unusual activities
financing and helping mr epstein so it's
it's the the the you know the rich get
richer the poor stay poor all that stuff
we know it's gonna work they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna track you in
your poop
but you will never be allowed to know
when bill gates poops that is that is
mark zuckerberg off limits not allowed
hmm i would need to talk to a blockchain
expert to know more about if they could
track if it would track
everybody does it track the entire
blockchain like if someone knows your
address
they know your transactions but no but
it's not even that remember we talked
about how facebook knows things based on
things you might not realize
you can look at certain wallets and see
all of them
as a blind you know public key
is just a code you don't see anything
but the computer sees
five accounts that interact with this
one account they know that this account
interacted with this account and they
know this account was in chattanooga
that means if this one's in chattanooga
this one had to be somewhere near it lo
and behold this one interacted with that
account that account was also a few
miles from chattanooga boom
they know what city you're in they're
probably laundering through through
wallets well oh definitely a lot of
people launder the walls but what i'm
saying is
an ai can look at a big a big list of
all these different hash codes
and see something a human can't they can
see location data
they can see everything because it's all
connected they only need
one key right so imagine a sudoku puzzle
you've played sudoku you guys know you
need a few clues
and then you can solve the puzzle for
those aren't familiar it's like you know
you got it's three by three grid
and you gotta do one two three four five
six seven eight nine and it's got you
know you can only have one digit in each
row and you gotta figure out where it is
you give someone a few clues for a few
starting numbers
and you solve the puzzle a super
computer is going to look at the bitcoin
blockchain
and they're going to have just one teeny
bit of information this account
is a common is is a is a high volume
account
in new york city and from there they can
find out who else is in new york city
they can create a data visualization
because this one wallet only interacts
with
you know 50 accounts in new york and
only a few others outside of it
therefore the person's likely in new
york city
then they can look at who's interacting
they can see that person and they can
create an entire heat map
geographical locations to the best of
its you know like with high probability
they'll know who you are what you're
buying where you're going what you're
doing
everything they've already done it with
the far right
and they've said we know who's donating
and who's donating to who and they they
published it they were like
this french guy has just given a million
dollars to this alt-right guy
and they they they just know because
they can look at the wallets they know
the moment you say hey here's my key
send me bitcoin they know who you are
they know where you are they know what
your wallet is
and they can use that information to
figure out who the other people are that
you're transacting with
so they got it bitcoin is giving that
information up
welcome to the nightmare dystopia i
suppose but at least
you'll be rich if you bought bitcoin
earlier so like would it be
i'm trying to think like the us who pays
the u.s military they're paid in dollars
right now
if they start paying them in bitcoin
that means the people with the bitcoin
are going to be running the military
not the us not the taxpayers i don't
think we're anywhere near that yeah
and and another point to put out is you
could pay them in bitcoin and then when
some like 21 year old with a few
thousand bitcoin who's super rich shows
up
and he says i'm gonna control the
military because i have all the
resources
they pull out their gun and say no
you're not but what if he's like
just i'll pay you three times as much to
do the same work for me
the the the special interest says we are
legally allowed to cause physical harm
to your body
try it yeah do you know you know what if
it's a chinese guy though
yeah let me introduce you to a guy named
muammar gaddafi
what was he trying to do what was he
trying to do he was trying to create the
gold
dinar and african union currency that
traded
itself back what was sam was saying
trying to do he was trying to sell oil
on the international market without the
us dollar
they're both dead i wonder afghanistan
syria
also made similar measures so yeah you
if you step it's what ethan was saying
man if you step in front of the petro
dollar
don't be surprised when you no longer
are alive
most of the countries that are in the
news that are
looked down upon are getting crapped on
are doing that yup it's like iran yeah
russia
cuba russia also but also very
interesting there was a lot of comments
by the kind of establishment types
especially janet yellen
biden's treasury secretary elon musk and
also bill gates recently
that made according to some people made
the price of bitcoin go down
because uh bill gates said that we could
uh we should definitely get rid of
bitcoin
janet yellen said it was extremely
inefficient
which is absolutely hilarious coming
from the former federal reserve chairman
and very duplicitous and extremely
hypocritical
so well should we jump super chat yeah
real fast before we do do you remember
that
military guy who said we're going to be
invading like nine countries a night
yeah yeah i talked to him
uh and i interviewed him about that and
when i brought it up he looked like he
saw a ghost
wesley clark wesley clarkson we are
changed wesley clark i play that clip of
him
saying that he was at the meetings and
they told them the plan that they're
going to invade all of these countries
and he brought it up on an interview
with amy goodman on democracy now
they were doing a live segment sitting
down talking about it i talked to him
and he was he literally freaked out and
he turned white
and he ran away wasn't he he wasn't
wrong he was when he brought it up to
him he was talking about the countries
that you just brought up that are like
refusing opec basically the opec dollar
yeah look i and i've had
um conversations with friends who say
that there are
humanitarian things to be done in these
countries
also um but i think that that misses the
broader point that there are lots of
countries with humanitarian things to be
done
but are not monetarily beneficial
and i'm i'm kind of a realist because
i enjoy living here i have a i have a
nice life
i i recognize though that for me morally
there's a trade-off
right you know i that's exactly the
point i used to make to my friends when
they're voting i'm like
you know i i have a friend who was
telling me they're like a lefty activist
and they wanted to make the world a
better place and i said no you want to
make your community better
like no no i wanna make the world a
better place and i was like you're using
a laptop that was made of foxconn
laboratory where people are committing
suicide and mess
and she had a realization that
no you're not fighting for the world
because while you may be more effective
with a laptop
it's that that that product is is is the
result of all this suffering
so it's a it's a it's a moral trade-off
yeah i i do become disappointed
sometimes
when um this conversation becomes
uh the the moniker isolationist is hung
on it because
i grew up in los angeles around a lot of
left people
and and there was always kind of an
anti-war bent
and somewhere
10-15 years ago that shifted and we were
humanitarians
and i i just don't i i just don't see
that
i don't think of myself as an
isolationist but i do
you know it becomes a weird thing well
let's take
super chats if you haven't already smash
the like button and don't forget to go
to timcast.com become a member for
exclusive members only segments
let's read some of these comments we got
jonathan galterini says i'm sorry i'm so
angry
can someone talk about how biden just
bombed syria after
all these peace deals we made how does
this help any country
send my brothers and sisters home leave
the east alone i hear you man nope
i hear you you're not wrong snowboard
dan says tim got a new hoodie i did
ethan gave me his american glutton
hoodie and t-shirts
that uh uh and i said that looks pretty
cool i think i'm gonna wear it i'm
jealous
i don't wear luke's shirts i killed my
clone today
what does that mean uh the idea comes
from a
good guy mentor of mine named tom kyr
who actually played a a character based
on him
in the television show chance and um
through conversations with him he has
this
philosophy that he uses to train
um combat people people
he he's a martial arts instructor and uh
basically the point is every day
you have to better yourself so you meet
to battle
a version of yourself that's 24 hours in
the past and if you can
best it you've won the day and you've
killed your clone
that's cool i like that all right well
let's read some let's read some more
wow look at this join my colt says tim
looking dope tonight oh they seem to
really like your hoodie huh
brent seigen says hey tim i mentioned on
your stream on the first
that my brother grant has watched you
for years but didn't become a member
and i asked you to bully him a humbly
request you up your bullying and call
him out by name so i have a sound bite
to play him i assume he's the
same last name as you grant saigan why
aren't you a member
join we'll make we'll make a special
account
that oh that we can only post kind of
just for him to yell at him
it's like everyone's like what is this
weird thing i can't nothing's happening
when i click on it
but only your brother will be able to
click on it
all right let's see mike jesus on your
vid earlier on gamestop the current
market has more to do with current
government bond interest rates not game
stunks
i am not a cat all right i didn't think
you were but all right
tons of people are commenting saying
biden bomb syria by the way what's up
with that
we did not i didn't bomb seriously i
barely got into it so what happened what
yeah i don't know
i didn't i don't know facilities that
were tied
uh allegedly these are the official
sources of what we're hearing right now
at iranian linked facilities that were
backed by some of their militia
again very still murky details we just
got this announcement what did they bomb
what are the consequences what are the
uh amount of people
that were killed here we still do not
know this is all
nuts man he's going to start a war with
russia 36 days russia
also increased the number of troops that
they have in the region so
of course did the united states recently
and turkey is also on the border and
turkey's the big wild card here because
they're a member of
nato and they're in favor of of course
taking over more of
syria which the united states is against
and nato and and
um united states are butting head inside
of syria and now they're saying they
want women in the in combat roles and
they want they want him in the selective
services
this timing
[Music]
liberal economic order of the british
and the americans that are trying to
dominate the globe with military races
are
losing the plot if they think that the
world will not unite against them
this is insanity well it's they won't
unite against them and this is the thing
i've been saying this was going to
happen on my independent media channel
for a very long time i said as soon as
biden's in it's only going to be a
matter of time until he really launches
the bombing campaigns and here we are
that's the meme
there's a meme it's amazing you guys
know the meme of biden eating ice cream
luke posted it it's a woman's with a
biden hat screaming can i have my two
thousand dollar check please
and biden goes yeah sure babe i'll bomb
syria
there's another one that says uh biden
tweeted america is back
and there's a there's a image of a
syrian child
saying oh good oh god with the drone
being uh lgbtq friendly all right we'll
we'll get into a little bit more with
more super chats but uh we'll read some
more
cerilio says first saw you in my name is
earl but mad props to you sir for
breaking the type cast your pigeon holed
into
great surprise guest tim and crew were
you pigeonholed
i think for a long time uh at the size i
was i was definitely
cast as a a very large person yeah
yeah i do and and uh you know honestly
it um
i probably would have had more monetary
success if i'd stayed that size
yeah yeah what were the top like three
films that you've done that you
loved the most um cold mountain
is uh my my favorite movie that i've
been in but then
you know uh remember the titans american
history x blow
those are those are mall rats those are
what's cold mountain it's a civil war
movie that anthony mangella directed
jude law and nicole kidman renee
zellweger
did you do a bunch of location stuff we
we shot it almost entirely in romania
wow oddly enough well uh
with your weight loss you got one of the
most vital roles ever you got to be the
podcaster in the movie the hunt
yes yes that's right yeah it's a great
movie we have another
spanky says bring back my name is earl
and then his little uh
hang ten hand sign please yeah it seems
unlikely there has
there was a jason lee and greg garcia
the creator went
and talked to some streaming platforms
about
doing more episodes and they got a
lukewarm response
so yeah i mean this was a really popular
show man it was huge
it was very popular but i think with
stuff like full house and willing grace
and the shows that did come back
there was such a huge
uh outpouring of like please do this
show
so we need forty three thousand people
to tweet right now hashtag
bring back my name that's my twitter
what trend that might do it
well you know hey if people really want
it
andrew andrew says is your flat ground
game on the level of johnny geiger
you've said you don't have a favorite
skater previously but give me a top
three keep it up guys
absolutely not johnny would annihilate
me that's that's that's ridiculous
johnny gagger's probably one of the best
flat ground skaters in the world hands
down
uh top three skateboarders oof that's
tough
always rodney mullen and i know it might
be a little cliche to say because he's
the godfather of street skating
but when i was younger and started
skating i watched rodney mullen videos
me and my friends did freestyle that's
why there's this video
my buddy brett shot 15 years ago it's
tim pool skating in a warehouse
and now has like 400 000 views the
craziest thing i'm like 19
but i do a one foot nose manual shove it
manual kickflip because
it's rodney mullen uh i i'm actually
going to say
uh elliot sloane right now do you guys
you watching skateboarding stuff
a little bit elliot sloane man he's got
a mega ramp in his backyard but it's
like a double mega ramp and his videos
are some of the best
i watched that vert skating and i'm like
i wish i could do and i wish i could do
just a frontside
air on a 20-foot vert ramp not gonna
happen i'm too old
and then um maybe uh aurelian uh gerode
gerard probably pronouncing his name
wrong but he might be i think one of the
best skateboarders on the planet right
now if not the best
just in terms of all around skill and
ability so there you go
all right we got j manny all says canada
didn't need
conscription to get 1 million people to
volunteer in time of trouble during
world war ii
with a population of 11 million very
interesting
interesting zack 30 says frankie
staccino
is on timcast omg boy meets world
changed my life been a fan forever since
then and watched your journey unfold
much love
everybody's gushing over ethan
[Laughter]
i think that that show was
happening before these people were alive
i really i really do
i mean i was a little kid when i was on
i watched it yeah um
but i i was like barely when did it
first air i was born in 1996 three
yeah okay i watched it i enjoyed it it
was a staple
in my eyes fred savage's younger brother
because i was a huge wonder years fan
and i gotta say us brothers maybe a
better actor than
i don't know you guys are both awesome
but they were good these great
surprisingly amazing
yeah it was fun oh check this out and uh
no salazar says george romero shot day
of the living dead at the same mall mall
rats was shot is that true
i didn't know that wow that's hilarious
watch them both sides back to back
maybe maybe make a short film that
combines the two universes
yeah the kevin smith zombie universe
zombie mall rats that was yes
gordo fabulous has screw mall rats
here's five bucks for having randy on
bring back my name is earl well you guys
have all tweeted it let's go
i don't look i'm it would be amazing if
that happened
amazing if that happened but i i think i
think it
requires a lot of people who owned my
name as well which network was it
um fox fox
fox owned it oh so it's disappeared on
nbc
really so it'd be a disney plus show i
don't know disney you need some more
mature content i don't mean like mature
rated i mean like more content for like
the older generation i turn on disney
plus and what do we get
we get a lot a lot of kid stuff you know
a lot of kids stuff
i mean they got they have simpsons and
family guy and doesn't he plus they got
to bring back my name is earl
all right let's see we got here
let's jump to raymond field says so our
dumb president already is launching
strikes in syria and is promising action
on the second amendment but remember
folks orange man bad oh yeah i know
biker bob says ethan are you still
looking for a ranchero i have one
from mn i earl oh for my name is earl
ah those cars were awesome my wife would
be pissed if i got one
that's how it goes a lot of people are
just saying
my name is earl my name is earl uh
oliver mccrea says oh my god it's
it's it's my name my name is not earl
love your show keep
finding the good fight here's a good one
uh bobby bob says ethan your weight loss
has been inspirational to me
while i'm still struggling greatly i've
got i've gotten the working out part
down
seeing you as helping me with the mental
aspect nice
you have a any any quick simple easy
advice or is that just a myth
no no i i do i think that for me the
most
important things that helped for long
term were the idea of allowing it to
take time
not needing it to be immediate
and figuring out stuff specifically with
uh
exercise that i could do every day and
wasn't going to be
something that i either wound up hurt or
so exhausted by that i couldn't do it so
i now exercise for an hour a day six
days a week
and they're they're workouts that i
could do forever it's never going to be
too much
yeah right let's see we got this one
from perrick i'll just leave it there
jocko disagrees with you colonel david
hackworth handled draftees in vietnam
and he said they performed well too
all depends on the quality of leadership
draftees question chain of command more
than volunteers
yeah you know luke wasn't it true that
the nypd said they only hired dumb cops
i remember hearing something about that
i don't know if it was specifically with
the nypd but i remember if an officer
uh scored two high on the intelligence
portion
and it wouldn't surprise me because if
you want people to take orders and not
question them
you usually have to lower the iq of your
candidates
yeah uh debased zoomer
says ethan your character in my name is
earl had sleep apnea
do you have it if so did weight loss
help i was diagnosed two years ago and
have been getting treatment ever since
with a cpap machine it's made life
livable again
yes i did have it and i don't anymore
losing weight
losing weight handled it for me yeah
amazing yeah it's
it's a brutal brutal thing to have it's
like we wake up at night like
yeah you're not breathing yeah but i i
would do it and not be even
aware that that was happening well my
wife would listen to me and go like hey
wake up you're not breathing
wow um and i was just tired all the time
and i would like fall asleep driving my
car
because you weren't getting rem sleep
like your brain couldn't get sleep
because you know is that what was
happening yeah
crazy it's awful yeah jacob
dobinspeck says i work for a company
that makes parts for raytheon as much as
i don't like the military-industrial
complex i really like the money from the
military-industrial complex
keep us open during kofit that's true
you can't you can't deny that people
like business is going to be booming
under a biden presidency yep
congrats i guess black pelt of confucian
says hey tim what's up with the shirt
ah so many people are watching and
probably wondering why i'm wearing this
hoodie it's it's ethan's podcast
american gluten american gluten yeah and
so he gave me swag
and i was looking at the hoodie and i
was like oh that's kind of cool i'm
gonna wear it yeah
because i thought it was the anarchy
symbol yeah yeah yeah it says american
dream
the the g is open it's not a full circle
not a full circle but i thought it
looked cool
you're getting there it's good it's a
good visual
corey carlson says hi tim love love you
love the whole group
tell ethan's plea congrats on getting
ripped fun fact
the same amount of people have died in
gender reveal accidents and shootings as
the amount of people that died in the
capital insurrection
did you guys see the latest one like a
gender reveal exploded and killed
yeah it's gotta i'll tell you what make
a birthday cake and make the inside blue
or red or pink or whatever
there you go you cut it and like oh hey
look i got a cake i have four kids we
never did this right just tell us wasn't
i didn't even
know this was a thing you know you do
you have a
a trump hat or a biden hat it's like
it's a boy so wait wait it's a
republican it's a republican
all right let's see robert kindly says
you can't go to war with china if you
are too busy going to war
with with china joe biden hey there you
go
and then pointing to his head clyde the
slug says tim
just bought two i am a gorilla shirts
also chocolate covered pretzels
those are those are quite delicious uh
and don't forget you can get your
exclusive
our pillow it is the the first version
over at teespring go to timcast.com
click
shop and you can get the i am a gorilla
t-shirt and the our pillow which has the
my crossed out
and we are working on the campaign for
the official
original our pillow which is just behind
ian it's a burlap sack full of packing
peanuts the prototype that's the
prototype
i am not joking when i say we are going
to sell this now yeah
there's probably it's not a joke folks
i mean it is it is funny but we're going
to do a joke and i'm not kidding i've
looked into getting commercials on fox
news
and i'm pretty sure i'm pretty confident
that will happen i'm pretty confident
we're going to sell something and we're
going to have
a our pillow it is a burlap sack full of
standard home packing pieces
watch well we got to figure out a bunch
of regulatory stuff
but i plan on not an actual pillow yeah
i just i just you know what i was
thinking like an artwork
yeah exactly where where is anybody you
know like
like elon musk has all his money and he
does some fun stuff with like his tweets
but he could literally have a giant
golden statue of like i don't know
pac-man just built and put somewhere for
no reason so glad he doesn't
and but why i don't know opulence but
it's not about that it's about like okay
so maybe not that
but doing things to kind of like sort of
shake people a little bit like hey wake
up
live do something make life fun yeah
that's why i want to do the hour pillow
because i want people to be like
this is the worst pillow i've ever had
but it's mine and i got it i'm excited
for it
it should be funny it'll be funny there
you go do you know that there's no
nft art what is that non-fungible token
art what some of it's worth millions of
dollars too and it's just
written into blockchain using ethereum
cryptokitties
something like that weird interesting
cool never heard of it robert galera
says ethan your body transformation
video was an inspiration
exercise has been routine in my life for
the past two years thank you nice thank
you
seven empire says my man ethan was seth
from american history x
looking good brother you were in all of
my favorite shows and films growing up
who remembers boy meets world
that's right yeah
minister roni says spotify unfollowed
your podcast for me so it's time i
joined this really cool website
i hear they sell great pillows everybody
that's right
the best let's see what is this
skillsbot
nice to see louis lastic on the show c
plus average coach
yeah that was a line from remember the
titans they can't play it in our line
right on yeah i got into college john
mickey says ian it's a sailboat
yeah maul rats references i'm sure a
bunch of super chats are going to be
the mall rats references i love that
movie good movie i'm kevin's such a
genius man
yeah oh i love his raw form you know
i mean look at this man curious mishap
says yo ethan i remember you were my
favorite character on that canceled tv
show would you ever advocate for a
continuation of my name is earl
i would do it i think everybody all the
cast has been asked they
all said they would do it cool it really
is just a matter of demand
i think i think i think you should do it
i think we i i got disney plus
um and i canceled it but
because of uh you know some
controversies and stuff but
what are the disney plus controversies
the uyghur the uyghur thing and
oh yeah yeah and gina carano and then i
was like the gina chrono thing was
was dumb but the the the the weaker
thing with the act was it the xpcc that
was like ooh
i have a question about the gina carrano
thing because i i just don't know
was she a regular on that show yes okay
yeah yeah she was uh
i don't know if she if you consider her
to be
a supporting or recurring character
recurring perhaps but she was in
like what like more than half of the
episodes in each season
maybe maybe not yeah i mean listen
again maybe around half to play the
devil's advocate
when you do a television show for a big
company like that you sign a morality
clause
and if and it's not even defined if you
do something that they find
immoral they can get rid of you i did
mention this when when she got canceled
i did say listen
while i recognize i thought it was
absurd she got cancelled because what
she said was don't demonize your
neighbor she didn't say anything about
republicans she didn't compare
republicans to anybody
she said they demonized their neighbors
in nazi germany
i said but listen the reason why they
hire actors is like you're you're
you're an advertisement yeah they they
want to put your name you know first of
all they want the talent obviously
but for for certain people you know they
want top billing
they want people to see this and say oh
i love that actor i love the shows they
do
and so you're acting as a kind of
salesperson for the brand outside of the
acting you doing it
i mean that's fair too you're the actor
you're the expert yeah no that's exactly
it and
uh and if you do something that
tarnishes
their brand they're they're very quickly
going to get rid of
they don't want that kind of the the
problem is the
like that you could you could drop an
ice cream cone on the ground and then
people are gonna scream at the top of
their lungs to try and get you fired you
know what i mean yeah obviously not that
simple
but they the media really spun what she
said completely out of context
i think it's it's a really dumb analogy
but i understand the gist of what she
but she didn't make an analogy
well the meme whatever the meme was she
shouldn't have posted the image because
the image was actually from
i think it was the image that got her
camera that was right that i think you i
would absolutely criticize because i
don't i wouldn't post them like that
but all it said was in nazi germany
they had the you know before the
government was able to do what they did
they were propagandizing people to
attack their own neighbors how is that
different from attacking someone on
their political views
right she didn't say anything about
republicans so that was insinuated and
then now people are saying she compared
republicans to like
you know the jewish people that she
didn't do that yeah at the core of the
message was
stop demonizing your neighbors for what
they believe and i was like if someone
on the left posted that
people would be like that's right trump
supporters should stop doing this yeah
everyone should stop doing it
but but i think i think it is fair to
point out and i definitely did like
right away like
if you work for disney and you post
something
that's why a lot of actors keep their
mouths shut yeah that's why i think it's
rad that you came on the show to be
honest
there's a lot of people that i know and
respect who are like i'm really worried
i'll get in trouble if i you know come
on the podcast and
we talk politics and it's like i don't
blame them
it's really you know i i'm disappointed
for sure but you know i talked about a
lot of people it's hard to tell someone
will you sacrifice everything in your
life now that there's a political battle
my personal answer is like i will always
stand for what i believe in
i understand why people might be you
know worried or scared
we don't even need to talk about
politics happen we just kind of choose
that path but there's so many other cool
things to do and talk about
like health first i definitely think we
need to try harder to focus on some
positive things in life as well
entertainment like just i mean your your
presence your aura and your history like
the
power of that industry is so i don't
know how you would say it
immense i mean that's one way to phrase
it but like just pervasive it's so like
it's storytelling it's one of the most
ancient human arts and
mass media is you know but it's so it's
enhanced it or intensified it you know
it's incredibly powerful when
when ethan walked in everybody was
gushing and i'm just like
it's funny that we can have these really
high profile political figures that we
listen to every day that inspire people
and it's like oh wow hey it's cool
cool to finally meet you but then you
know you come in and i think there is
something really important about
entertainment that we take for granted
when i was younger i used to actually
feel the opposite i was like we waste
too much time on entertainment we don't
focus on the more important things
and now that we've inverted it and
politics has become pop culture i'm like
can we please go back to talking about
movies seriously because we went too far
we we want to focus on the important
things and
we need to have relief humor the word
humor and human is like inner
intertwined we need it
people are saying here look check this
out uh why doc says bro remember the
titans is my all-time favorite sports
movie
shame it's only on disney plus i had to
go out and find the dvd
like the fact that you know we watch
these movies and we're inspired and we
feel good
it's it's we need we need to bring that
back into pop culture
because you know i was talking to a uh
uh like a podcast network recently
and they were talking about politics and
news and stuff and i said i gotta be
honest
like i talked a lot about culture we
talked about sonic the hedgehog a year
ago and birds of prey
but when the movie industry kind of
stopped and covet happened and
everything went
when election and politics became pop
culture it got so intense
and everyone started fighting i'm like
there needs to be a split
you know we need to focus on politics
and we need to focus on the things that
give us relief and joy
yeah to calm down otherwise we're gonna
explode hey i have i have an audience
question sorry i have to interject i'm
being pressured
by my audience here um i have a friend
who wants to know what you guys both
like
best about michael melis his friend is
michael malus
[Laughter]
i okay michael are you texting lydia
maybe maybe not
i so i just want to say um his
humbleness
i think michael malus has perfected
how to use twitter yes because he's not
he's he's nothing he writes is cheap
none of it is like super obvious
or or if it is you have to be paying
attention to me while and at the bottom
of it
he's actually the most caring guy it's
it's really wonderful i
love michael mallis when michael tweeted
i'm gonna i'm gonna say what are you
tweeted
i hope you're all ready what do you
think rush limbaugh is saying to george
floyd
right now something like that i i really
like the tweet you know why
because it's implying they're both i
would say in heaven together yeah in a
good place
and uh i just thought it was michael
knows how to craft his tweets perfectly
that's why i said like you know people
say like who do you look up to in life
is never really anybody to be honest
but in terms of like ins like whom
keeping my eye on
i watch michael malus tweet and i'm like
this guy's he's figured it out yeah
i've not seen anybody figure out like
he's figured it out it's definite
inspiration
i love him and and uh i'm very excited
about it
did he just make you promote so now
we're promoting his book
michael mouse's new book the white pill
not only the white pill he's writing the
anarchist handbook
oh interesting because you know there's
a lot of
the the left anarchists get very very
angry
at the at the anarcho-capitalist
non-aggression principle the free market
right but lysandre spooner was around
pre-dating emma goldman um anyway
the point is there's sanity
from all those guys all those cats had
stuff to say that was
rational at some point so yeah he's
going to write a really cool book i'm
excited yeah
hard work i know all right we got philip
a booty says 584 pounds here and i have
been on opioids for eight years
and the dosage was slowly going up and
up until i started to remove carbs
sugar specifically and i started taking
vitamin c and d
uh magne i think mg magnesium yeah zinc
and collagen daily
i have stopped taking opioids dropping
from a hundred plus milligrams a day to
none
dude awesome incredible congrats awesome
that's some of the supplements i take
collagen yeah yeah we promote collagen
with one of our sponsors
so always give a shout out to biotrust
those guys are awesome help the show
make the show happen
jordan's shaffer says join the family at
timcast.com
youtube lost all my confidence in it
when i couldn't donate a normal amount
easily
thank you for the amazing content y'all
are the best so we uh
so right now what we're doing with the
website we have just like extra segments
we'll do we we reserve
the more like the things we're not
supposed to say on social media
because we can send the website we can
swear we develop stuff but
what we want to do with timcast.com but
maybe a bigger brand maybe we'll start
with timcast.com is actually original
shows
so other podcasts but even fiction stuff
that may be down the line i think we
might start with mini docs
and man on the street interviews and
just get more and more content and
really you know
bring some you know bang for your buck
all right chris pavetto says you often
say finite resources
how much longer until the media praises
thanos 50 concepts
sell me a 40 year old using the internet
for 20 years on a vpn
how will my years of past history help
my future
the thanos thing aren't they already
doing that
the great reset sacrifice yeah i mean
well they kind of have accepted that the
human population is
there's too much and the people are
going to die regardless so they're
trying to like
get ahead of the curve on that well the
human population is going to go down
according to many statisticians and
scientists
by the year 2044 according to some
estimates or even sooner because
a large swap of the western populations
are declining in numbers rapidly
and there's a big huge loss of sperm
count there's a huge rise in
miscarriages
there's a huge rise in infertility so
the population is dramatically going
down in shocking ways that are going to
have huge profound implications that i
talk about on my youtube channel because
this is huge
stuff that deserves more coverage
definitely but also isn't there
something to do with like
as uh groups move out of poverty
they have less kids yes that's got to be
part of it too right
yeah well yes that's why western
countries and japan are
dealing with this but each country is
different china is different because of
their one child policy that a lot of
uh elites like ted turner call for in
the united states individuals like
prince philip and bill gates kind of
you know advocate for depopulation as
well so there's a lot of different
variables the population in china
might normalize the population in africa
is going up dramatically so
all right we got ryan curie says hey tim
i love your show been watching luke
since the old days
wondering how you think a right-leaning
moderate like myself should go about
debating emotional leftists and people
who believe everything cnn and
mainstream media tells them
be nice to them if they get angry
apologize for making them angry
swallow your pride when i have a lot of
conversations with with like my lefty
friends
and i'll say something i try to be calm
they'll get agitated
because it's like if there's something
they they're confident in but they
actually don't know about
so they say they'll say something like
you know oh i think biden
is better than trump because he's going
to get us these checks and then i'll say
well it's been you know how many 30 31
days he hasn't got the checks to anybody
if they get really mad i'll say
something like hey man i'm i'm sorry i
didn't mean to make you angry i
you know i just want to have a
conversation you know we don't we don't
have to talk if you don't want to and
just
try to be friends the uh it's not easy
it's not to it's not super easy because
everybody gets agitated everybody gets
elevate you know you know the tensions
elevate
but you know really what i do when i
have conversations with people
is if they go off the deep end and get
super tribalist i'll just say something
like
i don't understand why you're being so
mean you know i'm sorry
that you got angry we don't have to talk
about this because you're not going to
solve anything if people are screaming
at each other
so it just really depends depends on
what your goal is sometimes uh people
have told me they
intentionally try to have like they'll
keep engaging with someone who's getting
angry because they want other people to
see it
so one thing i often do is i try to be
overly polite
in any conversation particularly on
twitter because my attitude is look
someone is watching this conversation
and they're going to see me saying
i didn't mean any harm i'm sorry i mean
no disrespect and the other person
saying f you you [ __ ] how you're so
dumb
and people are going to gravitate
towards the person who's nice that's the
easiest way to do it i suppose
first thing you got to do it's proven
all right let's jump down let's see we
got here in the old super chat box
rocket punch says hi ethan big fan and
so happy to see you healthy
great work man please call whoever can
bring back santa clarita diet
oh that's another show that was
cancelled too early
um that i was in the last season of yeah
i don't know who to tell but but the
creator of that was one of the writers
on my name is earl so i think
it was in the same universe somehow i
gotta say i'm not i don't i don't know
if i have the
the the clout in any capacity with you
know with the audience
to actually get my name israel to trend
and come back but i would say it would
be like the coolest thing ever
if like you know it happened that would
be awesome and it's just like ethan went
on this show and they were talking about
political issues and cultural issues and
war and then the audience was like we
want my name is earl
that'd be awesome that'd be so cool yeah
what should people tweet i don't know
what should people tweet i haven't
no i have no i don't know how twitter
works anymore
well you know i think if if if everybody
told all their friends they're bringing
back so many shows they're bringing back
frasier
are they yeah they're bringing back
frasier yeah paramount plus
right tons of shows it's time to come
back man yeah it could happen
daddy t says tim what's your favorite
skate video besides your sponsor me tape
uh i don't have a sponsoring tape i
never i've never done anything like that
i hate filming
i just i hate filming skateboarding i
filmed some stuff that i was proud of in
the past but my favorite skate video
um what's it called is it fun by santa
cruz
maybe not i don't remember i you know i
honestly i don't really care for
for skate videos all that much or
filming i just like uh oh
nope sorry easily it's brett novak's
killian martin a skate escalation hands
down he's a friend of mine
but the music so good and killian martin
an amazing skateboarder you guys should
check that out
on on on his channel brett novak it was
one of
like a super famous video went
mainstream viral so that's it was crazy
to see regular people who didn't skate
watching the skate video like wow that's
super cool
all right dj medeiros says tim i once
read an issue of popular mechanics from
the late 90s
in it there was an article that said all
the ufo technology from area 51 and
wright-patterson air force base was
moved to a base in northwest utah
that's 200 square miles interesting
well that would be fun to learn about i
suppose
publius the good said trump did that to
m1 just saying
well his cabinet because he was trying
to bribe the people who
i can't say that on youtube he was
trying to bribe people but they still
turned on him
nate boy uh bowling or nate boy
why don't you make dual stream at
timcast.com so you can just shut down
youtube stream and keep streaming on dot
com for exclusive segment
people won't have to wait an hour or two
thoughts on that
yes so we are actually working on a
bunch of new tech for the website we're
going to be redoing the
graphic design and building everything
out and one of them is going to be
essentially what you've just said
as well as other technology we're going
to open source and provide to other
people so they can have the same access
as we do and uh i don't know if that
what does that mean i look like a lefty
libertarian right
i'm gonna free the code ian we're gonna
make code that can benefit all these
other people that they can use on their
websites and we're gonna get away for
free and then we're gonna start a
civilization on mars with it
i guess maybe ambitious titan tech 90
says i went to
i went to high school at papio south and
we were the titans
we got denzel and the original titans
coach boone to come visit when we opened
you look great brother keep up the great
work thank you very much
ashley parrish says whenever i see ethan
all i hear is the tuna
one of my favorite movies you look
fantastic and now if i didn't know it
was you
i would never guess it was you that has
been funny there have been a few
instances where people have been in
arguments online saying i'm not me
that's just a little weird
transformation man yeah i mean that
photo
from your instagram where it's like you
before and then after and you're like
standing tall and flexing it's like you
look totally different
yeah it's like the the other one is you
know a marshmallow another one's a
viking warrior you know what i mean
let's see
uh yeah thinking out loud mentions uh
nft crypto art people made 3.5 million
in december
new art auction today on christie's
currently at 2.2 million expires in 14
days
so what what is that it's i don't know
how it works but it's
art tied into i believe they use
ethereum but it's some blockchain
i don't know how it works at all but it
is it's uh it's a piece of art that you
store in your wallet
and you know ultimately nobody can take
it away from you it can't be seized
i mean it works because people want to
store a value i'm saying i don't know
how it's fabricated yeah you know
a lot of art is people buying something
so that the money they have sits in a
hard asset you know
alternative jk says oh snap shout out to
ethan supply on tim cast irl
i was going to say it's vince from art
school confidential but i'll keep it
subtle
by the way i'm digging everyone's
fashion sense tonight what what a
thursday and now i finish fanboying
oh man rudy c winslow's ethan you abused
a clown in vulgar
you were in vulgar i was dude i saw that
movie and i was like
what though is this movie yeah
was that kevin smith it was uh no um
did you ever see this show um comic book
guys
yeah i love that show it was one of
those wait is that kevin and his friends
kevin it was the comic book shop that
kevin opened yeah
and then the one of the guys in that
directed
vulgar oh yeah which which guy i don't
know i wouldn't know my name
i haven't seen in a while yeah i've
never seen it so i don't
know how to describe it it's like a
bunch of guys sitting around talking
about johnson yeah
all right we'll just do uh we'll just do
a couple more here tyler toth says hey
ethan can you give some insight on
working on the ranch one of my favorite
shows cheers
a lot of fun i think um you know it's
it's this odd thing in hollywood where
sitcoms are kind of looked down upon a
little bit
um because multi-camera shows
came out and were so kind of creative
and interesting
that people kind of stopped thinking
well of sitcoms but as a human being
sitcoms are much easier to make and um
you live a better life so yeah i mean
that's what i have to say about the
ranch
it was a lot of fun to do paul s says
my name is earl spinoff with ethan as
the lead would be better
and a smiley face yes all right last one
chef gab says love the stream tim
you guys gal should have an episode
talking about magic the gathering
no just political well we're planning on
doing a gaming
uh channel and everything too we
actually got a streaming rig set up so
we're getting there
i guess the main challenge is we can
only work as hard as a human being can
work
and we need more human beings so i will
tell you
i think i'm looking now for like two
journalists and probably some developers
but we stopped to suss out what the full
plan is going to be before we can get to
that point
tim actually got me a uh a little magic
the gathering gift
today bob ross original art
so excited neat beautiful favorite
artists imagine the gathering is a card
game
one of the core components are called
land cards and they took
bob ross paintings for the art on the
cards and it's got bob ross's name and
it is beautiful it is incredible
little mistakes happy little mistakes
all right ladies and gentlemen thank you
so much for hanging out we're going to
be jumping over to the exclusive members
only segment a little bit
so make sure you follow me on all social
media at tim cast
check out my other youtube channels
youtube.comtimcast youtube.comcastnews
we do this show on irl live monday
through friday at 8 p.m but we are on
all podcast platforms
so leave us a good review you know shout
outs on these platforms give us all the
good stars and all that
but don't forget to like share comment
and uh subscribe to this channel as well
but seriously sharing
is the best thing you can do it's
greatly appreciated and we'll see you on
the next show but
ethan you want to shout out anything in
particular your podcast i have a podcast
called american glutton and you can see
images of me on instagram at ethan
supply
there you go so right now i am posting
and memeing about the current situation
in syria on
luke we are change on instagram and
twitter if you want to support me you
can
on thebestpoliticoshirts.com and i'm
pretty close to 700 000 youtube
subscribers on my main youtube channel
we are change and if we could get
to that milestone it would mean
absolutely nothing
but i would smile for a little bit it'll
be you'll be like it'll be cool so
so thanks so much for having me i'm ian
crossland you can follow me in
crossland.net if you'd like to see me
play video games with my friends as well
you can follow me on twitch at ian
crossland.tv was that where i know
it's twitch.tv slash ian crossland i'm a
gorilla buy a t-shirt oh yeah there you
go
and i am sour patch lids on twitter and
i am real sour patch lids on instagram
and gab and sarah bachelet's on mines
we're gonna talk about some uh hollywood
stuff i think in the in the exclusive
members only segment
i got so many questions but there's also
some stuff happening with lady gaga
i know a lot of people probably say oh
we don't care about lady gaga but this i
think is fairly important so we'll talk
about this
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
over at timcast.com bye guys
you